Hello everybody, hello, hello, sorry I had, um, Matara just
messaged me and I was just, like, catching up with her, uh,
and, oh, okay, I'm, I'm so sorry, guys, I'm, I'm so sorry
that I took this away from you, uh, but, but, this is what
Deadlock took away from you, uh, that you're gonna hate
Deadlock even more, I'm so sorry, um, but, But Matara
actually wanted to drop by, drop by in between her visiting
Mint, and then she wanted to have, like, fly over to me as
well.
But then I answered the message a bit too late.
Yeah.
I, I, like, she messaged me at a very bad time.
I, that was also why yesterday I was like, that's a wake-up
call.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry, I'm sorry That was also the reason
why Yesterday I was like, guys, I I need to stop I need to
get out of there I need to stop She she messaged me during
Peak deadlock out Like when my addiction was at its fucking
peak I was I was trying to Was locked up in the deadlock
dungeons She prioritized rank over friends.
Honestly, very relatable.
I would not be surprised that you cannot judge me.
That is very relatable.
Like, it has happened to all of us.
I am not the only one who has done this.
You can't just blame me for that.
Let's see.
Let me organize all of this.
I was just catching up with her and stuff and just talking
about how she's doing and everything.
That's why it's a little bit late.
But yeah, anyway, other than that, let me see.
I did write some stuff down.
Oh yeah.
Oh yes.
Okay.
Apparently I can talk about it.
But it has not It has happened to most of us, maybe not all,
99% of the population.
It has happened to 99% of the gamer population.
Next, see, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
You know, like, those times when you get invited and stuff,
and you're just like, oh, I, guys, you don't understand.
I really need top 500, right?
I really, guys, you don't understand.
I need, I am on the grind right now.
I, guys, okay, it's like, would you write?
go outside or be inside crying about your ELO.
Obviously you would rather go outside, but like the ELO, it
has a grip on you.
You don't understand.
It has a, it's like, it's like holding you back.
It's like, don't leave.
I'm like, you're so right.
I won't leave you.
You're like, that's right.
Don't you want to stay here?
You're so nice and comfy in your room right now.
Everything's right here in the room.
And they're like, you're so right, that's like, I ever leave
you you're so I'm like don't cry no no like don't cry I'll
I'll be here for you no it's so that's a shame that sounds
like I would never leave you I am not part of the 99 forward
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um I don't
even have chows I was getting to that I was trying to fix
that I got distracted by his conversation.
All right.
Let's see.
Excel.
Thank you.
Super Chat.
Okay.
I think your math is a little obvious.
You're right.
It was like, it's like 98%.
Thank you.
It's like 98%.
Dark, Dark Mo.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome.
Gordon.
Thank you.
It's super chat.
Magic.
Lock her Steam account to only stream out when she has lost
gaming privileges.
Thank you.
It was a super chat.
Look, there was a little bit of wake-up call because I felt
so bad because I was like, I'm so sorry because I replied
back just, I think I replied back like a day to a day or two
too late because you already had all the travel plans
booked.
And I'm like, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm a little out of it right now.
I'm Mr. Broken Bonding.
Mr. Pritchat, thank you.
Thank you.
a toxic abusive relationship dokey plus you have an
addiction to elo they use super chat they can think i can
fix them i can fix them it's okay it's okay i i wasn't able
to fix overwatch i wasn't able to fix apex i wasn't able to
fix rivals i can fix them i keep deadlocks different guys
guys that deadlocks different i okay okay but like no it
wasn't day or two i was a week late to replying back to
Matara.
It wasn't a week ago.
But I meant like a day or two.
If I replied back like a day or two before, like when I
replied back, it was a day or two late in terms of she had
already all of her stuff booked up, like all her travel
stuff booked.
And so I was like, I'm so sorry.
It was such bad timing for me.
It was really bad timing for me.
I'm so sorry.
He caught me at a really bad, at the worst of my addiction.
So, but now I'm answering messages again.
I'm, guys, guys, I'm recovering.
I'm on step 1.5.
I'm answering.
I'm answering my messages.
I know, I know it is on me.
I said, I did, I told Matara what was going on.
I was like, I also told, no.
No.
I don't know.
He's been...
He knows.
He knows he gets food.
No.
I'm streaming.
I already gave him a little bit of food, too.
So I was just, like, the coast...
To, like, coast him.
But I'm recovering now.
I'm a recovering rank addict.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Doki Bird, and I am addicted to Elo.
Now you guys are supposed to say, Hello, Doki Bird.
Welcome.
a problem i may have a problem but i i look guys guys no you
don't understand you don't understand like i know like
deadlock don't treat doesn't treat me well and i know all my
exes also don't treat me well i know like i know like
overwatch or i have those apex like they we we all i've i've
always hadn't had like you know they've always you know but
they're so nice to me they're so nice and they're so kind
and you just you just don't see them like how i see them
guys you just they They don't show you the side I see, guys.
You don't understand.
Like, you know, when they give me Elo, like, they don't show
that side to you that I see.
And that's why I keep coming back because I know I can fix
them.
I, I, you just, you just don't know.
You just don't know them like I do.
You just, she never, what did she, what did you think?
It's different.
It's a hybrid genre.
They're trying new, it's not just a hero shooting.
It's not just a MOBA.
It's a hybrid genre.
And it's like the first of its kind.
And you don't, you don't, you don't know him like I do.
Anyway, so, so I felt so bad, but, like, you know, there,
there will be a next time, you know, there will be a next
time, I will answer my DMs next time, I will answer my DMs
next time, um, anyway, but yeah, uh, so, yeah, I was just
catching up with Matara and stuff, and I, told her like oh i
have to start stream so i'll catch up with you later and she
said yeah that's cool uh anyway um other than that other
than that uh i'm gonna be very busy for the next the next
week because um i i was told i can announce this but two
days ago i found out uh so what happened was uh um apex
approached me uh slash respawn approached me to organize a
last minute uh tournament for to celebrate the Capcom Street
Fighter collaboration for Apex Legends.
So originally had another creator doing it, but they had,
unfortunately, something came up for them and they had to
drop out.
So they were asking me if I could organize it for next week.
And I was like, at first I was just like, oh man, I was just
like, oh, that's, oh man, within a week, yeah.
um and I said yes I think I can do it I think I can do it so
next week there will be a apex legends street fighter uh
tournament and I'll be organizing um so today after the
stream I'll be very busy I'll be I'll be very busy very very
busy busy because I have to recruit people I have to recruit
people get everything sorted out it's not gonna be like a I
don't want to make it a try our tournament and we're gonna
be trying to um i'm trying to try my best to make it as fun
as possible from what i've learned previously while
organizing tournaments um it's not gonna be vtuber only i'm
planning on trying i'm gonna try and invite street fighter
people uh or people in the fighting game community because i
think that will be really fun uh i think because it'll you
know it's here to promote street fighter as well the new
street fighter skins and i want to see if i can invite some
of the street fighter people to participate and i think that
would be a really fun crossover between like street fighter
players that's why i'm trying to try and see like what we
can do to make it not super duper sweaty uh and uh have it
more like you know i won't have hide and seek in there i
want to have like i want to have some game modes in there
that's not like you know melee only or something so i want
to have some fun game modes for people for those who aren't
who uh are not And I'm definitely gonna learn from it.
I'm gonna learn from my previous tournaments and just try my
best to balance it as best as I can.
Hey, sir.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There will be a next time I'll answer my DM.
She lied as naturally as she breathed.
That's me.
14.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Very nice.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But more so, like, you know, just because, like, you know, I
know like some streamer, if you have never played Apex
before or never really not played Apex.
before or just not are not like very uh like are not like uh
fps players so i do want to make sure like the games itself
or or like you know maybe they're in controller um but games
are not too hard for them so because it is you know and i
asked if i could uh if i could be provided like treat like
the skins as well like skin codes for um the street fighter
players as well they said they can so you know it'll be you
know they'll have something fun to get out of it as well
like that they can use during the tournament.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Once again, going for B-Four, that doesn't know how to say
no, but I hope it would be fun and not stress you out too
much.
Also, make caustic no grenades around.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm going to use the bathroom real quick.
I will be right back, guys.
I need to use the bathroom.
Back.
Guys, oh my gosh.
Guys, did you guys know Bob the Builder is British?
All right, emergency news alert from the Doki News Network.
I just found out that Bob the Builder was originally a
British TV show that was dubbed in, I guess, United States
English.
He's what?
He's a British?
Yes, he's a British passport.
I thought he was homegrown in America.
thought he was grown grown american he was british i oh my
god that's even daddy okay i'm gonna give him a little bit
more food
guys oh my god breaking news breaking news on dokey news
network i i can't believe it and why did they have to redub
him i
guess they're like americans would watch it he's british or
some i don't fucking know i
I don't know.
Maybe, I mean, I mean, that's the reason they're like, we
think we won't watch Bob the Builder.
He has to have an American accent.
My world is ruined.
Americans can't under, little American children won't
understand British English.
What do you want?
You want, you want our kids to grow up like pansies?
Like, I don't know.
Maybe that's what the network's on.
They're like, we don't want our kids to suddenly be British.
um um but as i just found out uh i so yeah the kids won't
have a british accents i guess in america um anyway in three
days i'll be at vexpo birmingham uh i did i'm sorry not even
three days in two days i'll be at a v at opening concert in
vexpo birmingham uk um um But yeah, the only reason why I
just found out about it is that they're doing a reboot.
I don't know, I guess a sequel to Bob the Builder.
They're bringing back Bob the Builder.
And then people were like, why does he sound like that?
And I legit don't even remember what he sounded like,
because all I can remember from Bob the Builder was, was Bob
the Builder.
Can he fix this Bob the Builder?
Yes, he can.
Like, that's all I can remember from Bob.
Bob the Builders.
I didn't even realize it was a different voice.
So it blew my mind.
I was just like, oh my God, wait, he's British?
He's not homegrown in America?
I didn't realize he had a different voice.
Gongo, thank you, Mr. Richette, thank you, thank you.
I was watching Mixmaster's first token tournament.
I got whiplash when I saw the first pillar's name is Bird
Eskout.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yeah, super exciting.
I'm really thankful for Apex for reaching out to me and
thinking of me to help them with organizing this tournament.
They've always done a lot for me, so I wouldn't mind doing
this as well.
And it's like a sponsorship opportunity as well.
This is a sponsored opportunity for me.
And there will be a prize pool because it is a sponsorship.
by apex so I know like you know I know it's hard to make a
fun tournament when it has money involved but also try my
best to make it not uh not like uh like too much focused on
um I guess too much focused on the the regular game mode you
know on a turn I'm gonna try and make it not like uh like
have like a fun game modes in there even though there is a
prize money involved so there's more like i guess like rng
involved in terms of like who can win some of the prize
money um i want to see if i could do because it is a i think
it is a let me double check um because i know they raised
the prize pool too uh for it uh because it is a big
collaboration like it's with street fighter so it's a huge
collab uh it's a huge collab um um collaboration with apex
and capcom so oh yeah it's gonna be a 30k prize pool uh so
i'm trying to i think i'm gonna try i do want to see if i
could like split the money because it's 20 teams let me see
30 let's see maybe we could have it so no you can't i was
like so i have to figure out how to split the prize pool as
well uh so it is a 30k tournament that i'll be hosting i
don't know i'll be doing casters thing where it's just
everybody just plays the tournament um and so we'll see how
it goes like i said i was um every i was added to the group
conversation um i was added to the group chat yesterday so
today i have to focus on like the planning of everything um
so yeah i'm gonna be a very busy week for me um because
today after the stream i'll be looking into recruiting
people and seeing who's down to do it uh because it is very
last minute so i understand like some players some people
might not be able to do it so it's because they need more
they need a heads up like you know so i'll see what i can do
i'll see i'll do my best guys i'll do my best i hope i just
wanted to be a good experience for every and learning from
what I've done in the past.
I just want everyone to have fun.
That's like my first prerogative is that I want everyone to
have fun and not be sad.
That's a huge goal.
I just want everyone to have fun.
If not, they all get street fighter skins at least.
You know, at least like I joined Doki Bird's tournament.
All I got was a street fighter skin.
You know, at least, at least at least some tournaments don't
even get you anything at least you'll get street fighter
skins I at least I was able to I was able to request if my
the players could participate and can get the street fighter
skins and they said yes so at least you know if we all we
all get something here yeah they're really cool let me show
you guys the collab skins look actually look really cool I
was like, whoa, uh, because they actually look like the
characters too.
Uh, Street Fighter, Apex, Collab, skins.
They made one for, uh, Pathfinder as well.
I'll show it, you guys.
There's like two for, I think Gibraltar one is the coolest.
Gibraltar is Akuma.
Yeah, at least we all leave with something.
That's my goal.
Um, but Gibraltar is Akuma.
I think, I think the Akuma one looks really, yeah, the Akuma
Gibby looks fucking sick as hell.
thing that was my favorite out of all of them oh my god i'm
trying to find a good picture for it but they're all like
condensed as hell ryu i won't say it wait i won't say it ryu
ryu might need to go back to the gym i he has the um he has
the he has he he's been on a diet a
might be the pose though i'm pretty sure it's the pose i
think it's just the perspective i think everyone else looks
sick i think akuma gibraltar looks sick as hell though
oh my god the pathfinder okay the the blanca the blanca
caustic though he's he's they finally made him green hold up
but shouldn't lead though
but yeah i akuma is my favorite one and the akuma shield too
i wonder if it's gonna be the kuma shield as well
i think they all look amazing i think they came rio was like
i'm done beating people up with my fist
It's...
Ryo went from melee build to archer build.
He's like, that's it.
I'm bringing my gun.
Oh, speaking of gun.
Did you guys see Kairi of a gun?
For...
Yeah, Ryo became a zoner.
He's like, that's it.
Enough.
um but it's super exciting um really uh i'm really looking
forward to you know working with apex again for this uh
there might be another tournament in the horizon um with
apex too uh but uh but too excited that they approached me
uh uh to help with uh uh that they trust in me they put
they're trusting me and able to organize a tournament within
for next week, especially for such a very very special event
too for Street Fighter as well.
Since I've, you know, done a lot of stuff with Street
Fighter before in the past and with Capcom before.
So I feel like it's a really nice partnership.
You know, I feel like it led to this moment type deal where
I've done stuff with Capcom, done stuff with Street Fighter,
I've done stuff with Apex and Street Fighter too.
for thinking of me and I hope I'll be able to organize
something fun for everyone within the week and you know have
a fun event for everybody and for the audience, for the
viewers as well to watch.
I don't know if I'll have a casting thing doing for it.
This is like a for fun thing.
I might, I don't think about it because I don't know if this
needs to have casting but I'll see.
I'll see.
Because I'm like thinking, because I don't know wig is busy.
I know wig is, he's always so busy he's like such a busy guy
um and i don't know if uh you know if i can get wig i would
rather he i don't know if he would rather participate or
cast for it but um i might ask wig if he wants to join in
but i know he's a very busy guy so if he's like he can't
make it it's totally cool um but we'll see how we'll see
we'll see it's all just more so we'll see how it goes for
next week Today, I'll be very, very busy because I'll be
focusing on, you know, organizing all of it.
We're focusing on organizing it and recruiting people for
the tournament itself.
I haven't really fully decided on.
Oh, I definitely would definitely want melee mode just
because it's Street Fighter.
I think it'll be really fun.
Just because it's Street Fighter, I think it would be
fucking hilarious just to have like some sort of like some
one...
Okay, one idea I have is like, we all spawn in, can we, oh
wait, actually, you can't do that anymore, right?
We're like, we have no ring, and we all spawn in on the
boxing area, and then we'll just have 1v1.
I don't know if we can do that, though.
I don't know, because I remember you can't turn off the ring
anymore.
So I don't know if they put that back in where I can turn
off the ring of fire.
I'm not sure if it was super chat thing thing and it was
like but they'll take too long that's the thing the thing
I'm worried about is that's gonna take too long it was gonna
take too long to have 1v1s with everybody in with 20 teams
in and then we're like all right next next event put 10
people in yeah unique is custom code for i'm pretty sure
we'll get we get custom codes for it because it's a
partnership with battlefly um because like all tournaments
all official apex like i said this is an official apex
tournament so it's sponsored by apex it's backed by apex
you're gonna tweet about this tournament later on and making
graphics and everything for it um and uh or or we could have
this so like each team nominates a captain and we all
surround the ring and holy that's such for each team
nominates a tribute and then there's we all surround the
ring and like yeah and that would be go on so much that
actually would go on a lot faster yeah each team now i'm
cooking guys i'm cooking a game mode each t because it's
like street fighter each team nominates uh tribute and they
have to put on a street fighter skin and yeah to put on
tribute skin and we'll have a bracket and then we'll have a
bracket we all watch it we're all gonna watch them feed each
other up like oh my god wait that's gonna be so fun at joe
bring putting street fighter in the apex like and they have
to put on street fighter skins too um yeah so it's like it
promotes street fight the street fighter costumes as well as
well as the um as well as apex in general yeah i'm fucking
cooking right now that's gonna be so fun we're all just like
watching in the arena being like yeah that would go so hard
i'm writing it down i'm writing it down um uh let's see
until the final so we'll have like a bracket and then it's
like we'll like be like this person's next and then we'll go
one by one until we the champion yeah call it apex fighting
my coach can beat up your coach it's like district five
tribute all right i think i think we should that should
definitely be a game mode i think that is actually that's
that sounds so funny we should have that we we definitely
should do that as a game mode because it promotes like I
think it has, like, elements of street fight, like, elements
of fighting games, as well as elements of Apex in there as
well.
The Hunger Game Strikes again.
All right.
So, anyway, lots of exciting things coming up.
Also, I think, wait, let me ask this.
Because I feel like I've heard...
Let me ask Matara about this.
I don't know if I can talk about it.
Um, but yeah, anyway, um, I will stay in list because I want
to make sure, um, because I don't, I don't remember, I
vaguely remember her mentioning it, but I don't know if I, I
don't know if I've just made that up in my head.
So, so I'll see what she says if she has talked about it
before on stream or not.
Tressu, G-S-S, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
Oh, when does the big walk come up?
Oh, yeah, we should get that back sorted.
Because I heard Matara's getting back into streaming and
everything too.
So maybe we can bring back the big walk.
Oh, is it the Minecraft?
Oh, yeah, do you guys heard about that?
Yeah, yeah, that's what she mentioned that, right?
Yeah, she was talking about that to me today as well.
the Minecraft server um but I guess if she mentioned it
already publicly then I can talk a little bit about it but
she asked if I can help set up the Minecraft server uh for
the sloppy sister serve like because it's going to be a
sloppy sister server uh so everyone that's in the sloppy
sister server which is basically sloppy sisters Matara Amini
um and uh she wants me to help uh set up a Minecraft server
for everybody uh to use so I don't know if I'll be putting
any plugins in there.
I'll think about it.
I have to talk to them about it.
They wanted to be purely vanilla, or they want quality of
life stuff.
Obviously, I'm going to do add, I'm going to add the mic,
proximity, proximity chat, because I think that's always
fun, even though it's like a very small group, the sloppy
six.
Yeah.
Even though it's a small group, I still think proximity chat
is always fun, and people are just want to hop in and then
like, um, hop in and out, but that's one of them one of them
that um i'll add in uh and maybe i'll give them a tour of
dokey lot i could i could if they want i can ask them they
want a tour of my personal of the dragon server as well um
uh but yeah so uh i'll i need to think about like what
plugins to add what quality of life stuff they want um if
they want pure vanilla or just if they want like little
things in there more architecture stuff because they want
build things too on the server so i could i could add some
like uh more like um i can add maybe like a mod or something
in there for building wise so they have more options but
we'll see what they want anyway guys all right only i was
always like anyways time to end the stream we talking to y
'all yes i gotta go anyway let's let's play onimusha
And then we talked enough.
I guess it's time to end stream.
Alright, let's...
Yeah, my third...
I'm joking.
It's only Mousha time, of course.
It's only Mousha time.
Let me see.
Oh, yeah.
I just found out that the Wolverine game cost $300 million.
And it looks like that.
did you guys see the quality the okay i think the the facial
animation i i think they forgot to add facial animation oh
yeah here let me show you guys yeah okay i like i want to
know who did the facial animation for robert ream you should
have the dokey brick card i don't i don't think any one of
us is good oh maybe neemie i think neemie would neem and
matara and Actually, it's just, yeah.
And the only Nimi Matara Lyman will know how to play the...
I don't even know how to play the Jokey Bird Card game.
I don't even understand it.
But, like, look at this.
I can't believe this game.
I did not realize this game cost $300 million.
That's crazy.
It looks like maybe if it was a Kickstarter thing, then I
would understand it because any game that, like, where's my
Friday Night Funkin' game?
like but this game was 300 million dollars to make oh this
one uh this is the one i was talking about the motion
capture uh what happened to it this look at look at look at
this look at the i don't know it's just the i think it's 90
of it is the face it's actually it looks like he's on like
some botox shit it looks like logan was on botox or some
shit so he's not able to emote himself um i don't know i it
just definitely does not do it any justice he yeah he
definitely looks so angry i feel like he just has he has
like a little too much botox that he can't emote also this
one Okay, I thought this one was really funny for those who
didn't know that Kingdom Hearts is coming to Kingdom Hearts
is coming to fortnight and then Okay, I like how everyone's
so focused on Kairi with a fucking shotgun, but does anyone
not see Roxas with dual oomps like dual It was like my guy
but like look behind him.
There's Roxas with a with the yeah the dual the dual guns
like the dual uzzies sorry dual uzzies i don't know why i
say umsa is like i remember starting with you it's like even
rocks just looks so gangster yeah it rocks this moment dual
wielding uzzies goes so hard
Like that, I was just like, what the fuck?
Who the fuck needs a Keyblade when you have a fucking Uzi?
Also, for those who don't know, for those who don't know,
apparently the Kingdom Hearts Keyblade is only, can only be
used by Sora because apparently in Kingdom Hearts lore, the
the keyblade chooses the keyblade wielding so they
apparently if you buy the keyblade as like the the melee
because you have to buy the melee weapon to um to use it but
it's only locked to Sora so you so none of Sora and Riku
it's only locked to Sora and Riku so you can't use it for
any other character is you can't have a you can't have
fucking mr beast holding a keyblade it has to be only so you
have to buy sora or red or riku to have be able to use the
keyblade uh yo thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you it's all fun and games and then killing heart kingdom
hearts pull up blikies thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you uh Yeah, so it follows the Kingdom Hearts
lore.
Like, they're not allowed to.
They're not allowed to have...
You're not allowed to equip on any of the other characters.
So, so that's...
That's on Doki News Network.
It's beat...
Alright, and that's the end of the Doki News Network.
Now it's time for the weather.
Alright, now we're...
Now, actually, now it's gaming time.
It is Onimusha time!
Is this plugged in?
Okay, my controller was not plugged in.
It's like you're giving your little brother the unplugged
controller, but it's me giving it to myself.
Let's see.
Alright, Onimusha.
I mean, I'm super excited about the tournament for Apex.
I just hope I...
I just hope it goes well.
That's all I want.
I've been really...
Um...
You know, I always love doing events, but they're also super
stressful and everything, so...
All I want is just for everyone to have fun.
And have a good time.
Um...
Alright, ooh, more iron.
Okay, more upgrades.
I love upgrades!
Okay, guys.
We gotta do all the side quests.
Don't keep doing side quests and not main objective.
to be stronger because like okay i wouldn't care all right
the reason why usually i i don't do too many side quests is
because majority of side quests is like um extra bonus lore
or like you know it's like storyline b you know a lot of
side quests in games are just storyline b and they're not
like like good like they're not like upgrades that are good
for your equipment and stuff So this is, yeah.
So this actually will improve my build.
I can actually improve my...
Oh, he's dying.
Hello there, sir.
I thought I could, like, step over him.
Yeah, they don't make my weapon stronger, so I don't care in
other games.
Oh, and I believe we met at Yashijin's home.
Oh, shit.
What happened to him?
It's all connecting.
Yesterday, the three of us went to receive some water from
Ottawa Waterfall at the temple.
Yeah, like the items are actually benefit me.
Look what's happened to him.
I just lost my husband.
I can't lose him too.
What is this?
Oh.
Wait.
We'll look into this.
Wait, you got married already?
What?
She moved on so fast.
Didn't your other husband die like four days?
How much time has...
Okay, I'm not gonna lie.
Only one day has passed.
Oh, that's...
Oh, okay, that's the bro.
Okay, thank God.
Okay.
That's her brother.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, I thought like he said, she said husband.
All right, so that's her brother.
Okay, I was gonna say, bro, it's been one, like one day.
I didn't process the fact that she said brother.
I was just like, oh my god.
I just thought the worst of, you know, I just went with the
worst option.
It's this way.
She didn't say husband.
Okay, I got gaslighted.
I was like, I swear to God.
I swear to God.
She said husband.
There's no way.
It's her dead husband's brother.
Okay, dead husband's brother who she's like sort of.
Oh, I get it.
That's her new boyfriend.
Oh.
I get it.
It's the new boyfriend.
It's the...
I knew it.
She's keeping it in the family.
I just saw something crazy.
I was on my way to my neighborhood shrine.
What should I find there?
But the Gemma offering prayers to some sort of glowing
spirit.
Yeah, the side piece became the main piece.
They're praying to something.
What the fuck?
They're praying.
Ah, yes.
The classic samurai expression.
Oh, and ye old ancient Japan.
What the fuck?
All right.
Let's see.
Yeah, I know I met them before.
That's why I was like, what the fuck?
She's...
she already moved on to like her purpose brother mommy the
fuck this
alright that's what I'm saying like she literally she moved
on to the brother the next day damn
at chat GPT at GROC did people say what the fuck back then
looked to be a warrior of great powers which indulged me
limped in ear to my storytell it was at the imperial uh
curious monsters the power of light breached the other wall
i tend to drive out the insolent beast but failed uh i burn
with shame uh curse my lack of fortitude uh don't be hard on
yourself old man you did well to make it alive i'll deal
with the monsters stay out of trouble in the meantime she's
not really he's not guys guys that's not the point i'm
saying not a day has and she's already with someone she has
already moved on that quickly
his body is still warm i would be surprised if his dead body
is still in that house
mr samurai you're miyamoto musashi aren't you you just as he
described you oh forgive me You see, I was at the Yashuri
Kampirago shrine the other day when a strikingly handsome...
Oh, he asked me to give this to you.
So here you are.
Take it.
I wonder if it's still bitter if I go back.
Perhaps I even want to thank me.
Yorimasa?
Usashi, I would like to share with you some treasures.
Alas, I cannot recall where I hit them.
Save one.
We're showing you found using this drawing.
It's like a little sticky.
Man.
I get it.
Well, I'm not going to say no.
All right.
A dragon.
Oh, my God.
We drew that.
Bro should be a fucking artist, bro.
What are you doing?
What the fuck?
He drew this.
A dragon lean to an ony assays at the top of Kyu Mizu Zaka
slope on the back.
Yeah, that's impressive!
What the fuck?
Bro, quit your day job!
Alright, oh, wait, there's a treasure here.
I don't even know what it's that.
And he has a memory to draw that, too.
You might be...
What is it called?
gifted, like, really gifted that one and one talent?
Oh, there's a specific word for it, but I don't remember.
A savant.
He's, like, literally a savant.
I know all you guys are thinking of another word, but...
A savant.
Yeah, yeah, I was thinking savant.
Let's see.
Where is one?
Okay, we got only treasure right here.
I was
I was like, I know some of you guys are thinking of a
different word.
Yeah, I got it as a fucking savant.
I know you guys too well.
Does this tell me where it is?
Where is this leading me?
I don't know if it's leading me to the right area.
I'm having my doubts right now.
Why am I traveling away around this?
I reach...
Okay, I have to look at the drawing.
Alright, it's time.
Alright, where's the drawing?
God, this is...
Okay, I actually have to use the drawing for this.
Where the fuck...
Did I put it?
Where did I put the fucking art?
Hidden treasure.
Okay, there it is.
um find a place shown in old drawing number one jesus christ
all right where's the pagoda where could your master's
treasure be can you tell from the drawing well i need to
find the fucking okay it's right here look there's the
pagoda it's right here okay it's behind the house okay it's
like is it behind this house
it's one of these roofs I mean I found this treasure yeah
it's on the roof it's one of these roofs have it like how do
we get on top of the roof though
I don't know actually there's no ladder the thing is there's
no ladder around it's here it's on these houses because
that's a pagoda um so it should be unless it's the it should
be like around these houses here where the fuck is a ladder
yes i know destination reached i'm like literally walking
around trying to find the ladder right now
oh my god a stupid treasure okay maybe i have to go out
Let's see if there's a ladder.
Alright, I'm behind it now.
To battle.
What?
Okay, I'm fucking liars.
Where's the yellow paint?
Where's my Wolverine yellow paint?
Where is it?
Yeah, I know.
Battle, where?
Okay, there's ladders.
Oh my god, I swear to you guys.
Is it one of these ladders?
How the fuck am I supposed to figure it out if I don't have
my yellow pinks?
How can I play?
Wear the yellow shirt.
So I know where to go.
Oh my god.
Is it like up on these ladders maybe?
Have you any ideas as to where your master's treasure may be
hidden?
Okay, maybe the guy should...
Maybe the guy should have drew it better.
What is that guy doing up here?
Maybe up here?
Maybe it's this roof.
Oh, oh there it is.
Found it.
It was actually in the house before it.
Because I was like, oh I had the ladders on the map.
Not bad.
No sense letting this go to waste.
I had a feeling.
I was like, well it has to be on the ladders on the map,
right?
Because that's where all the ladders are.
I don't know, I thought there was a hidden ladder that I
didn't see or some shit.
I will go for this one.
At least it's good to know that they're not like it actually
is where the map tells me it is.
Yeah, we'll do that.
As the only context of any of the Wolverine stuff is via the
it's via the fucking clips I see on Twitter on the Joki news
network.
As expected.
The gambar are not praying to anything.
They haven't noticed us yet.
Let's get them.
Got it All right, holy shit.
They're so fast Okay, I did not expect them to be like right
here.
Oh, whoa
Fuck okay
Okay, that's fine all right nice really is that all you got
you fucker you're think my crypt my fucking crypt the night
this one guy is this one guy i don't know he just he just
knows me he he trained specifically to fight me you do not
understand his entire purpose is to kill me the game there
are not praying to anything I haven't noticed us yet let's
get them that's the guy that guy's the only one that can
kill me right on time you don't understand oh my god I can
Killing him!
Alright.
There we go.
It's literally just him!
Are you even trying?
I don't care.
I don't know what it is about him!
Get away from me!
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god, see guys, the moment I kill him, everything is
okay.
And the 14th, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
The moment I kill him, everything's okay.
It's literally just him.
Compose yourself.
Use the pillar's strength.
All right, nice.
That's fine, that's fine.
Big and strong later.
Alright, let's just pop the balloon.
Let's pop the balloon.
Let's whoop.
Pop goes the weezza.
Is that it?
Alright.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I forgot how to fight you.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wait.
I mapped it.
Jesus, crazy silk.
That was like fully powered up too.
What do you mean?
Holy shit, I fully powered that shit up.
Okay, this guy is tankier than the other ones.
I think it's because that's why he has the legendary on.
All right, there you go.
Oh, fuck.
All right.
Here you go.
Boom!
All right.
See, come on.
There you go.
Oh, thank I got in time.
Jesus Christ, it takes so long!
Why is it effect taking fucking forever?
Jesus.
Oh no.
Oh no, not electricity at the time.
Okay.
Two.
One.
Three.
Two.
four all right okay like this i'm doing this oh my god you
better get close to me all right oh okay that's instant done
nice better go back and tell them holy shit that took so
long to pierce this fucking block i didn't use two of my
special weapon for that that took much should have.
I guess because it was like, it has to be like a special
version of it, right?
Because I was like, I swear to God, the other ones were
easier.
The other ones that I did.
Alright, we got him.
Okay, where's the other quest line?
Alright, there's the butterfly.
I go to the only refuge.
Refugee.
Guys, you think the legendary one might be a special
variant?
I wonder if the legendary one is legendary.
Let's head into the only area.
Hello, sir.
I need to head downstairs.
Ottawa Waterfalls water is a blessing.
It's driven the monsters away and made our lives safer.
Alright.
Apparently it's killing some guy.
Maybe like...
It's so dangerous that not even the monster's like,
monster's like, I don't fuck with that.
Love, please talk to me.
Ottawa waterfall, it's up ahead.
Maybe its water is sacred enough to get the stains out of
those filthy clothes.
They're not stains, they're blood.
They're my trophies from war.
Oh, nice lead water.
Are you here to drink the waterfall's blessing?
If you'd like, I'll pour you some myself.
No, I'll pass.
Oh, how mean.
And after I plucked all my courage to offer too.
Oh my, he fumbled it.
Nothing looks in place here.
Yeah, she seemed very demon-like.
To the human eye.
No.
However.
something sinister is mixed in with the sacred water truly
mysterious maintaining the purity of this temple it's a
fashion statement exactly you wouldn't understand it it was
at new york fashion week
maybe there's like a dead body they're saying i won't be
surprised there's a dead a dead monster there a dead gamma
that's marinating the waterfall at at any extra seasoning to
it that's usually the case um i'll go this way yeah adding
extra seasoning extra flavor to it's like soup get my soup
get my soup suck if you're a veggie if you drink get my soup
and you're a vegetarian is that wrong they're technically
demons and they're bad people because like people being
vegetarians mostly because they don't want like to eat
animals but gamma aren't animals so like as a vegetarian is
it a substitute for meat well we know now that gamma are
involved this would certainly inhibit yasa jinn's work hence
the impurity of the sacred water it's like when you eat tofu
chicken Tofu shaped like chicken.
It shall.
And drinking the restored water should in turn restore that
man.
It's not yet too late for him.
Alright, so we just gotta...
Alright, where is it?
Where's the little spider?
Holy shit, where the fuck is that?
I know for sure they're gonna make me kill a demon
somewhere.
all right one down the orange downstairs it's this way that
lady is laughing a little too much for my liking commendable
work did that release yashagin's home it better wait she's
gone let's go and check wait the creepy lady the creepy
laughing lady is God where does she go hello creepy laughing
lady where art thou are you being a creepy laughing lady
elsewhere huh well the hall has been unsealed so things
wrong but but the sacred water is still contaminated yeah
something else must be polluting it so we find that
something else and kill it easy is the is the gamma peeing
in the water oh no oh my god to go all the way back guys we
have guys we gotta do this all in one don't you hate it when
they make you go back and forth like yo guys come on we
gotta do it all people are gone yep we're gonna be killing
something uh oh there she is creepy mask lady is that don't
you you again really i'd be so pleased if you'd stop
interrupting my experiments good day to you all right
goodbye that's it
All right
What the hell kind of experiment is that I'm actually I'm
curious what they are doing to it All right, now it's just
him All right, here we go.
Wait, actually can I just Whoa, okay, that's Whoops That's a
little embarrassing.
Oops Look it's because he ran at me guys.
I got scared
She's a guy.
Got two gems.
Allow me to find out.
Could you take me over there?
Oh my god, are you...
Okay, over there.
Okay, I was going to say, I swear to God, if you make me
walk over back up top again.
The sacred water has indeed returned to normal.
Oh, that's it?
What the fuck did she do?
And purge the Gamer from their bodies.
That's it?
We don't... What does she do?
They must have peed in the water.
They... I...
They don't tell you, but my...
My theory is the gamma peed in the water.
That water you gave me fixed me right up.
I'm losing track of how indebted I am to you, Samurai.
We gotta check the pH levels.
I'm not keeping counts.
And I couldn't have held on without you watching over me
through the night i told you i told you i spent so long
looking after my late husband in his illness but this is the
first time i've ever been thanked oh my gosh she's in she
has definitely moved on join you join me and your son that's
it wait that's all it takes i want that too lady i just met
can you be my new mom i'd be so happy to throw the The
body's still in that house.
That dead body's there.
Her dead husband is still there.
The coroner has not picked her up yet.
No shot.
It's supposed to be...
It's not wholesome if it was literally the same day.
The same day.
Yes, I know he beat her, but I still find it funny that...
I still find it funny that she...
It was literally the same day and she's like, I shall be
your new wife.
Into a new family.
A sublimely intertwined series of events and a story worthy
of...
Well, now she married rich, though.
You know?
Now she's in the rich family.
It's like her reward, I guess, for killing her as their
abusive husband.
And he's like, yay!
Good thing to go to good people.
Now, all Courtney have...
She got the good karma.
Good for her.
What a lesson learned.
Alright.
Let's see.
Any other quest lines that I have to do in any of these
areas?
Okay.
Jesus, what?
Oh, it's the goddamn stupid archer shit again.
I'll make sure there's nothing here too.
Alright.
We'll do this and then we'll go from...
Yeah, we'll go up and down.
Look, the dogs don't give me actual loot, I'm sorry guys.
I'm only here for real loot.
Oh, he tried to...
Oh my god, it's...
It's always you.
Oh my god, it's always you.
Oh my god, I'm slowly learning.
I'm slowly figuring it out.
If they can't hit me...
Okay, at least I know if they can't...
Oh my god.
God damn it!
All right, we got this guy out.
Okay, they can't hit me.
I can't hit them.
All right, at least we got that.
All right.
Here we go.
Can I hit them now?
Yeah, I can.
All right, there you go.
That's one down.
Wait, what?
What else is there?
Oh?
I mean, I got the random chest at least.
Like get my note.
What the fuck?
What a nice find.
Where the fuck is the last guy?
Where the fuck?
Oh my god.
Gamers never look up, I guess.
This fucker.
Oh, I gotta hate these quests.
So this one, I think this one, I hate those.
A-ho, I hate tights.
Oh, these guys are so annoying.
These guys are actually the most annoying ones.
Oh my god, and my pathway is blocked.
God, I hear the goddamn pig.
Hey.
Hello.
Oh my god, how are they gonna go up?
Oh, this way.
at least i know how to come out there you go all right
where's the other one how am i gonna shoot wait there's okay
i have to go here okay
oh the things i do for loot guys the things i do for loot i
just love loot
I'm not here.
I'm not hiding here.
Turn around.
What the fuck?
Oh my.
Oh my god.
He was here the entire time.
What are you?
That's it.
What?
How the fuck do I shoot this one?
There's nothing here.
What the fuck?
Okay, that's fucked up.
Where is the angle for that?
Is it maybe here?
Okay.
Oh my god, please tell me there's no, there is.
Oh my god, is this a thread-to-needle situation?
Yeah, it is.
I fucking knew it.
How do we get... Okay, it has to be up here.
Yo, there's nothing here.
Oh, peek-a-poo.
Fucking bitch.
Show yourself.
There you go.
Alright.
Alright, you got last one.
Oh, it's all the way back there.
Wait, how much loot am I getting from this?
Okay, that's actually good upgrades, though.
That's a lot of decent upgrades.
You gotta match my stalker skills.
In-game.
in game
what there's another one holy shit oh that was bullshit
that's actually bullshit I'm just gonna eat healers right
now because I have to fight this guy be on your guard it's
because I want to make sure I don't die from that one guy
over there all
right i love dual wielding it's actually so convenient what
the fuck well that was easy all right i know worst part
about this part this go tell that guy the good news this is
just all the back like i have to backtrack so much no
the bow is op but i'm also dual wielding right Whenever I
need to use the bow.
One hand on the controller or the other one on the bow.
Let's see.
Can I upgrade anything important that I should upgrade?
Oh, reduces detection.
That increases the power.
All right, we should get that one for sure.
And then...
Okay, we're going to increase the range.
range.
How about this?
Yeah, I don't really care about that too much.
Not gonna lie.
Uh...
I'll grab the heal one.
Guys, we don't need the Isan.
It's not that important.
No, it's not the only thing maxed out.
Now that, because that's the important one.
guys, because that one is actually important.
Okay.
Where is this one guy?
Oh, he's over there.
I'm like, where are you?
Sorry, right beside me.
Thank you for driving out those insulin truders.
Truly remind me of the great Yord Yuri Masa, and I too shall
draw inspiration from the mighty warrior when next I face a
monstrous interloper.
I wouldn't bother.
It won't do you any good.
Being a mighty warrior doesn't have that much to do with it.
Come on.
Just don't go getting yourself killed for no reason.
Trust me.
It won't do you any favors in Yuruma-Masa's eyes.
Hmm.
It's almost as if you knew the great man himself.
So, I thank you for your words.
You're quite right.
In dangerous times, we must not throw away our lives or not.
What is, Isan?
That'll be so fucked when I fight a boss that only relies on
Isan.
I'm just like, what is that?
It's like, now, Doki, did you beat the final boss?
You must use every attack that you've learned over your
course of the journey.
I'm like, oh, well, guess the world isn't going to be saved
today.
We're going to build upon it.
Everything you have learned in the entire game.
Did you have it figured out what they were praying to?
But I only learned one move.
Turns out they weren't praying to anything.
They're just trying to retrieve a last pet.
I see.
I think, well, what they were up to, at least now I can get
back to my own worship.
Alright.
I can upgrade another.
Upgrade my sword again.
Alright, now I can fight the guy with the metal hat.
It's time.
Finally.
Alright, wait.
Before we do, I'm gonna grab water real quick.
I need to refill my water.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'll refill water.
I'm back.
Well, Manny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All
right, here we go.
Hello?
Oh, that's a lot of dead people.
He died of natural causes.
And I see you in the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hey.
Musashi.
You see, we're Very mentally stable You don't know what
you're missing Musashi They're just sleeping.
Yeah, it's a slumber party take feels better than the last.
It's incredible Oh, he's high He's high on human souls.
I've never felt so good
There's just one thing.
What is this?
The second I stop.
I feel so alone.
Oh shit.
Alone with his gods.
He's gotta keep sucking on souls.
So alone.
I'd rather be dead.
Oh no.
He's losing the high.
Post soul clarity.
Like this.
Musashi.
The posts suck clarity, guys.
Oh, no, no, no.
Dry your tears.
Oh, my poor, sweet Ganyu.
Mommy is here.
You're never alone as long as I'm here.
Oh, she's a good...
He's a mama's boy.
I fear that maybe Gio Gio Anani like myself Why is she ugly
and you're not Pravity has broken her mind And corrupted her
form as well Can we help her?
I wish daily too That's her only At this point There's
nothing left to save Musashi Never mind I feel great You're
a mess, Gani You're a mess, Gani oh no not again let's get
you back to hell i remember that words never did work
between us did they we only speak sword right oh no in that
case wait that's not fair your conversation why does my only
not do that oh i should have corrupted her too
a stance.
If the enemy is in a counter stance, they'll return any blow
with interest.
Even too high, it won't break such a stance.
Only only strength will have any.
That's not fair.
Why is that?
Why does his wife help?
Not mine.
My wife just watches.
That's what the fuck?
What's that word call after like, you know, when you like
when they get high and then the high drops and then you're
in the lowest low.
There's like a word for that.
Me and a shower of blood, Musashi.
What more do we need?
Oh my god, I don't know her.
Is it...
How dare you?
Oh god.
Oh god, what are your attacks?
Okay, did I do it?
I did it!
Okay, I did it!
I broke your wife's mouth!
Die!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Okay.
Cut off what you win.
It matters not.
Oh, my God!
The pillar's strength could stagger them.
Weak as ever.
Alright, we got this.
Yeah, he's on his crash now.
Alright.
One.
Headshot!
Headshot always works!
I swear to God.
What?
Oh my god, this is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Alright, I got that.
Put your back into it.
Okay, got it, it's them.
Holy shit.
That's what I've been trying to do this entire time.
Headshot again.
Headshot.
Woohoo!
I can tell you as a second for him.
That's the worst part.
Don't miss it now.
No!
Yo, we...
Weak, so damn weak, you fraud.
Okay.
All right, there you go.
Oh, God.
Oh, this is fun.
You look terrible, Musashi.
Oh, my God.
You're awesome.
Crypto Knight!
Take his head, guy.
I don't know.
It's just, there's just so many arms.
I got full guy.
Okay.
I figured it out, though.
What more do we need?
There's just something about him.
Take this.
Here we go.
Oh god, there you go.
I'm in a flow state!
I'm in a flow state right now!
Oh god.
What the fuck?
Okay.
All right.
here we go headshot
okay all right we got that one let us teach them the meaning
of pain get it all right no no
okay cut off what you will it might has not okay There you
go.
No challenge at all.
Oh.
I knew it.
I knew there's always a second phase.
You know this ends with you in the ground, right?
I'm not losing to a monster like you.
Okay, it was.
I was just like, where's the HP?
Oh, God, he's a freak.
I was so sad.
I was like, why can't I heal?
It's cutscene, it's cutscene.
Come on, this is a joke, right?
It's scripted, I fucking knew it was scripted.
I fucking knew it!
It was a guaranteed loss no matter what I do.
What a pathetic friend you have.
Why did you die in the cutscene?
Also, what's the point of a second sword?
Like, why am I, like, Zoro, I'm scary as swords for no
reason.
He's like, come on, and do some drugs.
It's going to be so fun.
Guys, I think he might be one of those things.
I think he might be a bad influence on us.
Supper time, Gio.
There has to be someone to eat around here.
Let's get faded together.
Oh, I could first try that one.
I, like, I got too greedy.
I got distracted by his worm wife.
If human souls are what it takes.
Do it.
Yes.
Take a mirror will be so mad when I tell him.
Turns out Miyamoto Musashi was just a brute with a sword
after all.
Look how strong he was, though.
It was so strong.
It's just one hit.
The first one's always free.
And then I won't do the other one.
Just one human soul.
It could be a dying one.
He could...
I'll just do it.
What if he was like one day from...
Like, what if the guy was dying from cancer?
Like, come on.
He had one day left.
He's thinking about going off to human souls, huh?
Poor fool.
After all he said about not wanting Oni powers, doesn't he
even think about how Shizuka would feel?
I've chosen to trust Musashi's judgment in all matters.
Yeah!
What if they're death row?
That's true!
They're gonna be executed anyway!
I'll do the executions!
That's so, that's so confusing.
I get stronger and also one of the guy got locked up.
for being a really bad person.
Get a hold of yourself.
Are you a man or a beast?
Doesn't matter.
A beast isn't far from Anoni, you know.
You do well to follow his example.
You wanted to get stronger, no?
Take a step back, Musashi.
Ethically sourced human souls.
Exactly.
Anoni, they used Prachette.
Thank you.
And I'm Canadian, so it makes it a defeat for him.
Sorry, that's too dark.
As you can see, I'm not in a great mood.
If you hear the preach, come back later.
Ooh, careful.
He might cut you down and eat your soul.
Sorry, that's a little too dark.
Candace done a lot of fucked up things.
So you've lost.
Yeah, that has done a lot that you guys might not be aware
of.
Like hell I will.
No.
What then?
Are you going to start taking human souls?
And what if I say yes?
What to can that not do?
We're the European Union now though, guys.
That crazy?
We're gonna be in Eurovision and the European Union.
They're scared of us.
Musashi, just being tough isn't enough.
on what strength really means you've come this far starting
brawls and winning them but now you've just run into a hard
truth to live is to suffer it's actually half dead already
it's a teaching of the buddha what it means is that life
will not bend to your convenience no matter what efforts you
make and that's just how it goes all you can do is learn to
love the challenge so being a samurai is being a masochist
then if you allow it Hinagika was in that gauntlet you
better not disappoint her
there's like a Stockholm syndrome where you enjoy the pain
the love is to suffer Alright, let's see.
Do I have any upgrades?
I don't think so.
Alright, what do I have?
Did I unlock anything for me?
Ooh, new missions, though.
Aww.
Yeah, new side quest.
Alright, let's get the main mission out.
Let's retrieve the main mission first.
Oh, you think it was super chat thinking to get your wife's
in the chair.
Even worse, she's in my arm.
He might eat your soul was too far.
she gets the po the arm pov when i lost the gun yeah it was
just for a second but i almost did go down that path i don't
want to think about what that would have meant for shizuka
and i've got a long way to go
hey there's somewhere i want to go you know that big sandbar
in the camo that area's crawling with denma oh no don't make
me escort you no that's why why don't you wait for me to
kill you out of them and then you come over that'd be a lot
safer i'm in of course thanks oh i swear to god please not
be an escort mission please if i want to play escort mission
Okay.
The spirit mirror won't wear out no matter how much you use
it.
But try not to forget that you have legs as well.
If I all manage to surprise the one walking around eastern
Kyoto, some surprise might even be the good kind.
I think I meant just like the hidden chest in there.
I mean, I feel like I already loot a lot, a bunch of stuff
though.
I definitely loot a bunch of stuff just walking around.
Alright, let's grab...
Grab this one first since it's next to me.
Oh, I always get baited by the other checkpoints.
Could you...
The hair, the sword, the gauntlet.
You must be Miyamoto Musashi.
I've been looking everywhere for you.
You see, I was recently attacked by a monster Yasuo Kampiago
shrine.
Just when I thought I was done for it, a save by the arrow,
mysterious.
Might I add, rather dashing warrior?
You said I wanted me to give you this.
Yeah.
Oh.
It must be Yorimasa.
I caught one hand under my tree.
Oh, my God.
Please pick up at your earliest convenience.
Yeah, thanks.
Could you do us both a favor?
Remember where they all are?
Okay, a drawing lean to...
Oh, wait.
He is a savant.
It's Yoi Masu, or Masa.
A drawing lean to Oni Treasure States where the Buddha's
overlooked the flow on the back.
What the fuck?
All right.
Where is this treasure?
It's right here.
All right.
We'll grab this.
this first.
Oh yeah, I could start buying them.
You're right.
I'm going to go buy.
I'm going to get that mission.
Just buy some resources to upgrade.
You're so right.
I keep forgetting that he has so many resources.
I might as well just buy it since they're right there.
I'll kill this for loot too.
Whoops.
Oh look, everybody's partying.
Guys, it was such a good idea to hang out today.
Sure there's nothing bad's gonna happen to us.
I love you guys.
I'm glad we hanged out today.
Happy birthday!
Happy 333 birthday!
Yeah!
Hey me out.
Honestly, hey mister, he helped me with something.
Oh.
I woke up just up the road from here and lately, me and my
friends have put to put up with the most terrible racket.
Just look at my skin.
I'm breaking out.
They're your neighbors.
You deal with it.
I don't even know you.
Why are you trying to get me involved in your petty
squabble?
Oh my.
Kar, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Because they're not our neighbors.
They're monsters.
What do people call them?
Yenma?
Anyway.
You know your way around a sword, right?
I have seen your work.
hell ah so it's like that is it all right just point me in
the right direction and then wish they've never been born
all right her neighbors are again ma that's like wild all
right what the fuck just move why the fuck would you joki
remember it rent is cheaper there it's like living next to a
frat house but your frats are Our fucking demons.
Let's see.
We'll go here.
Actually, I'm going to buy materials for upgrade.
Alright, let's see.
What do I need?
I need cotton, iron, talisman, and horn.
Alright, cotton, iron.
Wait, which way is the...
Whoops.
This is where the shrine is.
Cotton, talisman, and horn.
man iron have you need of my aid cotton this one right
correct all right how many do i have five correct yeah
correct cotton iron oh i don't have a lot of money for that
i'll buy two very well iron this one correct correct i'll
buy two farewell my friends all right goodbye Yeah, those
are very expensive.
I'm always making money, so it should be fine.
I'm always killing things.
Cotton.
I can level up again.
Alright.
Okay, I might be a little broke right now.
Wait, actually, two more iron.
Can I buy two more iron?
Do I have enough for two iron?
I think I do.
I have to upgrade my sword one more time.
visit, Musashi.
Hmm.
Yeah.
As you, the city is in your hands.
All right.
Nice.
Well, they were super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki, it's been almost a week since the demons raided
my village.
They burnt down all the houses.
Surely the samurai is close.
Oh, I'm so, since you didn't order Doki priority, so other
villages paid a little bit extra for me to come over to save
their village from being raided by demons.
And he paid the extra $5 order so um I just have five I have
three more stops until I get to your village do not worry
Quilla I'll be there in like 10 minutes maybe you shouldn't
cheapen out on the on not paying the five dollar priority
fee I mean I guess you don't care about your village that
much I was all I'm gonna say I
guess your family's not worth the extra five dollars save on
you
all right let's see it's this way all right let's find this
photo oh my god whoa someone is here whoops
holy shit wait
What happened to me?
There we go.
Oh, you got him off.
All right, it's archery time.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
Fucking it.
That's right.
Got your butt.
Get out of here.
Trying to find a treasure right now.
Uh, Kuka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
feeling sick today.
Any chance you could say something comforting such as, I
would never make my cute dragon fight in a gladiatorial
battle except for my amusement.
See, that would be lying, Kuga.
We don't like liars.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Get ready for tomorrow, guys.
Ew.
Who is excited for tomorrow's Battle Royale?
Oh, maybe don't announce that.
Alright.
I need to actually kill you for money though.
Alright, we got the hat out of the way.
That's just a little sidestep.
Alright.
Alright, let me...
Let me look at the map.
It wasn't that good.
Oh, wait.
There was...
All right, nice.
All right, let's look at the drawing that he did.
It's next to a ladder.
All right, where is a ladder near me?
Wait, there's no ladders here.
What the fuck?
This one?
This is the only ladder that's next to me.
I assume it's this one, because there is a ladder.
here i've made it easy all right is there anything else all
right where is the fucking ladder
okay it's down here okay where is it not here there's the
pagoda
yeah it's right here there we go oh my god you have to be
right next to it too you get cheeses beating them in general
area they actually sat on the x marks the spot quite the
find I don't have food dad I don't have food dad all right
we gotta kill some neighbors too hey no food no food come on
you want to come up here no you're gonna walk away yeah i
thought so all right i fucking thought so i looked at him
and he's like no food and i'm like no food and then he
walked away want to open from this side oh man oh now they
closed the door too
yeah i go this way oh my god i have a natural party wait how
do i am I supposed to open the door?
There's a ladder.
Oh, there's a ladder.
Oh my god, they are hosting a frat party.
I'm gonna party crash.
Um, why wasn't I involved?
Oh my god, wait, it is!
It's somebody's birthday!
It is a birthday, but it's like, oh, guys!
You guys should have hosted a surprise birthday!
Oh!
mind if i join in oh guys you shouldn't have now all your
friends are dead number one fight that's what they get if
they invited me this wouldn't have happened that's all i'm
gonna say if they had invited me i wouldn't have killed them
now there's no now nobody's gonna have a party
local samurai attacks birthday party favorite.
I'm also broke right now.
So, oh, whoopsie.
Oh my god, they have everything, too.
They didn't even get to have cake.
Doki.
Look, I really needed the money.
You don't understand.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, wait a minute.
Where's the...
How do I leave?
Oh.
Oh, I might have to go up.
I might have to leave through this way.
Oh my god, there's more...
I just forgot about these guys.
Oh my god, there's that...
Oh, nice, that's good.
All right.
Thank god that's convenient.
Thank god for the fire.
Oh god, it's him.
Alright.
It's fine.
I'm stuck in the plane!
There we go.
The main party was up here.
The lady should be happy to hear the news.
Alright.
Then we get here.
We're Power Stone.
Oh my god, we were just gonna leave this out there?
That's a big fucking...
What the fuck kind of fish is that?
Damn.
Oh well.
There was a part...
That's not them.
They didn't invite me.
They didn't send me the invite.
Can't believe it.
Can't believe they didn't invite me to their private party.
That's their fault.
Now they're eating good.
They were eating good.
Now they're dead.
all right let's go this way yeah they were asking for it see
if i got the invite it would have been
fine just like that like that star bomb song the castlevania
song all right here you go
yeah that's that because i killed yeah because they didn't
invite me if they invite me i might have let at least one
person live I need to count on you.
No, you're quite handsome.
Why don't we go and take a little...
Wow!
Oh, a little corny.
And, oh, the salad.
You need it.
Just a little corny.
Oh, my God.
She's freaking out.
Got to spell it out.
I'll make sure you're...
Don't be a stranger.
Another time is supposed to be sure to stop.
by once you should have taken care of what is he is missashi
gay or something women we met two months two minutes ago
she's like what a gay
i got this swim
he is a madman he is married to his work toky
all right this way
Now I get the cotton upgrade.
Don't.
Don't the horn.
All right.
Which one is the only?
I have enough.
I don't need any of this.
Well, more red souls will be stressed.
So we'll get that and then we'll grab this so we can have
more red souls at least.
It's this important.
No, I'm going to save up then.
There's like two more abilities.
Like there's one big ability here that we haven't unlocked
yet.
That's going to be important later.
I'm used to Okuni asking for a favor like this.
You two have been getting along better after the incident
with Hinagiku.
I am most relieved.
You make it sound like we're a pair of toddlers.
That's not what you want.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, I should help him.
Gotta get my pairs.
Alright, drop down.
Where's my pair?
You're still a stride master, Samurai.
So strong you saved my life.
Yippee!
The open riffs?
I don't think I can do anything.
It's still blocked, so I can't really do anything here.
Alright, yummy, yummy.
Got my pair.
Where the fuck's the door?
I'm gonna get in.
Oh, there.
I have, like, a fucking bird.
Just hitting everything, but the hole.
Where is this hole?
Alright, it's this way.
Hello.
Is the escort mission time?
There, can you tell?
Tell what?
I can see a lot of corruption.
What a mess.
Under all that, is my troops' stage.
It's where we'd show our dances off.
It was a fun, lively place.
But then, Doku and the Gemma came.
yeah the troops scattered oh she lost everything and then
okay you're alive you're dead friends inside me i won't let
her be forgotten our kabuki dance is the proof that we lived
yeah all right everything will be fine I'll purify this
place in no time.
It'd be easy.
Masashi.
Thank you.
This is where I wash my hands down.
I feel bad for making you do this.
But there's nobody else I can ask.
I don't need thanks or apologies.
Hinogiku is lending me her power.
This is the least I can do to pay her back.
Honestly, yeah.
Oh, he's...
He lost his aura a little bit there.
Wait, hey.
How do you turn this thing?
He looked so cool earlier.
Is there anything you do know?
Use the aura, idiot.
Minus two aura.
The long thing for paddling.
It's in there, right?
You're gonna have a hard life if you even use a boat when
would a swordsman need to paddle a boat that's so true i i
swing things at with my sword me no paddle he only knows the
blade yeah let's clean this place up for them damn he lost
all his aura there he looked so cool earlier too.
God damn it's always the poison.
Let's get out of the poison for me.
Not again!
Okay.
There you go.
Alright.
I know.
I used that for earlier.
Is that all you've got?
Alright, then.
some things never change I just I don't know I just you're
just something about it okay we gotta use this climb up the
ladder I'm coming I'm coming to get you I'm coming to get
you there we go that's not very smart fucking idiot all
right nice stabby stabby
All right, is there anything back here?
I was trying to see if there's any hidden treasures.
All right.
Only power time.
Whoa!
I fucking knew it, too.
I had a feeling.
I had a feeling there was this fucking...
It was going to be a...
ambush too all right nice you're nothing come on where's the
fear that i
easy back where you belong i was like there's so much loot
here oh my all for me just lying there
whoa there's really there's nothing here to me on that free
loot that's just there no free loot for me oh you know they
like left the bait left the trail of loot for me too oh
ladies oh pretty ladies in the lakes truly get out of there
you got a death wish
oh they're like angler fishes aren't they oh it's an angler
fish isn't it with the hot sexy women calling for me are you
all right oh shit whoa okay i think We can make it work.
I mean...
We can make it work, right?
The eyes are boobs.
I still would.
Wait, do they actually object?
That's crazy.
the thought of everything, guys.
That's how it's done.
It's like the American dragon clip.
Like, nice.
Wait, I forgot.
Guys, I forgot how to kill people when they're up there.
I don't remember how.
God damn it.
I actually don't remember how.
The jackpot.
God fucking, I forgot how!
I just parry.
Okay, it's just parry.
Okay.
I figured it out.
I don't think he's dead, but it's okay.
I don't think he's dead.
I don't think I killed him.
Wait, I did.
I did.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, see you guys?
I told you I remembered.
I didn't want to go that way anyway.
I didn't want to go that way.
Oh, jokes on you.
They are prepared to fight.
Let's do this.
Jokes on you.
Okay, we gotta get out of here first.
Okay, there you go.
It's the pillar strength to attack them.
Alright, how am I supposed to use the pillar strength if...
Okay, that's it.
That's it.
You left me no choice.
Oh, you're gonna run away now, bitch.
Just because you got a little fire.
All right.
Oh, a little fire got you?
Oh my God.
I'm skilled.
Get out of here.
Why are you running?
I'm gonna go up here first.
Oh, you're an archer.
You're not doing anything.
Okay, there's another archer there.
There we go.
You're rather skilled with that.
Well done.
I think you could have won that twice.
Where's the tree?
Where's the fucking tree?
There it is.
All right, let's get that tree out of the way.
Oh, oh, he's still alive.
All right, he was still alive.
All right, let's get this tree out of the way.
Nice.
Okay, there was detected some treasure.
Was it here?
Oh my god, there were like so many fucking defense op, like,
tools for me to use here.
I thought I saw it.
Oh, I guess not.
I saw the treasure I got, but I think it was just the
environment stuff.
Oh no, I knew it.
Oh, no, it's hair.
All right, where's the hair?
Oh, my God, it's up here.
One's up here.
Oh, where's the next one?
Wait, where is the next one?
Is it here?
What?
I feel like...
Where is that?
Oh, maybe like...
Oh, okay, from this angle.
Right?
Where the fuck is that?
Okay.
How the fuck...
Okay, I have to figure this out.
Alright, lead me to it.
What?
Yeah, I know it's here, but where the fuck is the hair
piece?
It was above me?
I already got...
Oh, maybe I have to go up this ladder.
Maybe I have a POV from up here.
What?
No, I don't.
I don't have to walk around.
How do I walk around that?
No?
This is...
I don't know where this spotter...
Get to that spotter.
I actually have to go across.
It's like all the way on this side.
How do I get away?
Get to that side.
I must be missing something.
Oh my!
Look, it's not my fault.
There was no yellow paint.
Oh my god.
I fucking...
God damn it.
You don't even get to have my sword.
I fucking, you know, there's just...
God fucking damn it.
The Omnis Wall Run.
Oh my god.
The fucking random Wall Run area there.
Where is my Wolverine white paint?
I do find it funny that the Wall Run paint is highlighted in
yellow.
Oh!
Oh shit, that's what it was.
Slash!
Oh,
you think you're stronger than me?
That's fucking right.
Get out of here!
That's funny that you think you're stronger.
What makes you different from the others, huh?
Nothing.
Well done.
You're not special.
Alright, nice.
That was one-sided.
Let's keep moving.
Alright.
Let's grab the extra HP.
I don't need it.
Just to flex.
Grab the extra HP just to flex on them.
Oh, what do you mean?
Oh, my god.
Please tell me there's a high ground somewhere.
all right all right there is an issue i'm slowly getting
poison right now
oh my god please tell me there's a ladder somewhere oh my
god he's right here oh my god please tell me please let me
do this please let me do this before anything thing happens.
Oh, thank God.
No, God.
Oh, God.
I got just in time.
Okay.
It's fine.
All right.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
come on yes it'll take more than that all right the headshot
I've got you now headshot you always aim for the head
doesn't matter it always works 99% of the time be careful no
okay the grab oh please musashi
no i pressed it i swear to god pressed it too Yeah, it's
ringing.
It's axe and malice.
Oh no, not the axe malice.
Oh
That was close
Okay, that's fine Oh
wipe I swear to god.
I've I know I I know it It doesn't look like it, but I swear
to god.
I'm not
Oh my god
Oh, oh, thank god.
I made it just the time.
Time to say goodbye.
All right.
Finally died, huh?
All right, now we can suck.
Suck.
Suck the big rift.
Make me stronger.
All right, that's easy.
We cleansed it.
That was a fierce fight.
We dance now.
Everyone, let's go.
It's dance!
Yeah, I'm fine.
But I have a feeling this isn't going to get any easier.
Oh, wait, it's not over?
It's not?
What do you mean it's not over?
It's time to dance, everyone.
It's time to dance.
I'm ready to dance.
Alright, let's grab the loot.
Where's the bed?
Why is the boss music still going?
What else am I supposed to do here?
Why do I still have like the mission thing here?
What the fuck?
Oh, is there something back here that I missed?
Huh?
Okay.
Can't do anything here.
But should I get that...
malice thing?
Oh, well, I don't know.
I'm going to go get that malice.
Maybe I'll cleanse.
Maybe I have to cleanse everything and then come back.
Yeah.
Assume I just have to cleanse everything.
It's weird.
It's weird that it shows that, not the flower.
They are prepared to fight.
Where?
Oh, my.
Damn, every time I keep accidentally pressing the rock.
It's fine.
I'll let them live.
I choked.
Actually, maybe I can kill him.
Try.
Oh, my.
I don't know why I can't fucking...
It's X, right?
Because I can't parry because parry is A.
Okay, let's try again.
What?
Oh my god, I keep fucking it up.
I keep fucking it up.
Okay, we'll try again.
They should prove no much for you.
What?
Okay, whatever, whatever, whatever.
It's fine.
Is it not, am I pairing, and I'm out pairing it correctly?
Oh my god, I legitimately forgot how to do it.
They don't show up often.
Where the fuck is it?
Break Easton?
Where the fuck is the one with...
Okay, dealing with threats.
Dealing with threats.
Oh my god.
Is it just blocking?
Where the fuck is the wall right?
one.
I know I'm doing it wrong.
So I don't know exactly.
I'm pressing X.
Do I not press X while like blocking it?
Okay.
He didn't even do it shit.
He just.
Oh, Perry.
Okay.
So don't hold it.
Oh my God.
I was doing it in a way where how I fight.
Can I have Okay, I figured it out.
Oh my god, you live another day.
Yeah.
Eh.
Oh yeah, I figured it out.
I can die now.
I can die at peace.
I can now die in peace.
This stage belongs to a friend of mine.
We'll be taking it back.
Oh, there is a lot of stuff around me.
Fuck it.
Might as well.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I mean, I'll take it.
I'm just gonna use my normal.
You see, when you're standing behind someone, it's not big.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Maybe that works too.
Wait.
Oh, that was nice.
God, it's heaven's game.
Oh, another one of you?
I mean, here we go.
Here we go.
Here the bloodlust is unquenched.
Oh my god.
Do you want it again?
Mal uses this.
Boom!
Yeah, I'm fortunate for you!
Oh, shit.
I'm fortunate for me too.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Told you it's unfortunate for you.
Oh, no, now he can fly.
It's not fair!
No escape.
okay all right no escape there you go excellent oh no now
he's at phase three shatter all right are
you fucking kidding me it's not fair
yeah okay all right last hit this guy plays a little too
much rank go go go take a shower bro go fucking take a
shower you're trying a little too hard buddy
try a little too hard there a little bit too sweaty money go
go out bro how long was your last shower we need to destroy
the root phases why mom give you three fucking phases that
weird plant right I'm on it where is the last that is this
way yeah maybe maybe if they give you a fourth phase you
could win a fight we're taking back this stage I had to go
back to school but your don't quit your day job imagine
needing three phases just to die
exactly okay now i've cleansed this area yay everyone can
come out now yeah i'm surprised again i didn't fucking break
into the houses and take them there was literally no
protection to from these houses like no the big titty the
big titty water women my water women monsters are gone now
too what's the point
no remember what they took away from you and woe is me
Okuni's performance is the beginning let us watch that's
nice A free show.
Like, yay, it's cleansed now.
All our fam- We lost family and friends, but let's dance!
We'll worry about that later.
We'll worry about the funerals and the body cleaning later.
Yippee!
I missed the Titty Water Monsters.
I miss her.
To be fair, like...
If they had one more person, then it won't be symmetrical,
so maybe it's...
I'm saying...
Where would the six-girl go?
Is there... The formation's already perfect.
Where would the six-girl be?
You're a duo, yeah, but she's Beyonce.
You're not going to stay here with your troop.
I can leave this place to my friends for now I want to know
then she'll mess up the formation I'll join up with them
after we're done it was perfect all the more reason to it
was the perfect formation exactly see you back at the temple
hmm okay now they now they definitely need the girl why
didn't we say now.
Seeing Okuni in such high spirits made this all worthwhile.
We did it.
We should return to the temple.
We're heroes.
Okay.
I thought there was a...
Yeah, there is a shrine here.
Oh, it was right here.
I missed it.
We can enhance.
Just...
Oh, we got all of it.
Nice.
have so many malice like mass too for that and we need two
iron or we need one more iron and we can upgrade that too if
only we saved her guys okay
what happened are you guys okay are you guys okay what
happened are you two all right
An Oni?
Yes.
They don't attack.
They're sure he's not in Yenma?
You guys go on ahead.
I'll bring these two back to the troop and look after them.
I'll help you out.
We'll listen to their story later.
First, they need a bath and some food.
Which can you help with, Musashi?
Neither.
see so go back to the temple get ready to fight and wait
gotcha all right not
too bad i always gotta i said they were attacked by an oni i
can't be right yeah that's what i'm saying that's weird now
we should do as okuni says i think it's i think she's
tricking us there's no way it's an oni with that i can guide
you to a new source of my Oh, the village is returning back
to normal.
Oh, hello.
You know, there's a place in the city that's rather famous
among lovers.
If views are sublime, the breeze always gentle.
No wonder I'm so happy for you.
No wonder people find it romantic.
You see couples going up there after one after another.
Oh, to be young in love.
Right.
Look, I don't know what you're talking about.
But if you're so keen on going there, just ask some...
Oh, whoa, it's like he's asking me.
Oh, you can let me stand here if I had somebody to ask?
Anyway, Risa is singing it because I went past her yesterday
and there were still couples lined up patiently waiting for
their turn.
Damn, that guy was shooting his shot.
Yesterday, but he's crawling with GENMA.
That's good.
Something's not right.
I better head over there to see what's going on.
A lion dog needs my help.
Well, the lion dog has to wait.
unit items can now be exchanged is there actually a lion dog
near me oh wait there is a lion dog near me how very
convenient wait let me grab this treasure first
upstairs what oh my god there was a hidden ladder that
blended in so well with the environment too I would not have
noticed this hidden ladder because there's no yellow paint
on it guys
it wasn't even on the map that's when you know it's hidden
they usually put all ladders on the map and then for some
reason this one just didn't have one
all right hidden in plain sight
most samurai i need to talk with you so i'm a huge admirer
the great bone master your In your day, I was making my
daily pilgrimage to Yasukon Prago Shrine.
When would you believe it?
The mighty general himself actually appeared before my eyes
shouting, Aha!
I worked it out!
Oh, is this another treasure?
I fucking knew it.
See you again sometime.
I still can't believe God talked to the man of my dreams.
Anyway, here you go!
Another drawing.
Guess I should see where it takes me.
Damn.
These are just like love letters to me.
But we can just deliver it himself.
I knew it.
I forget every time.
I had to check how far it is from the people.
I had to check, guys.
I...
Alright.
I was like, how far are they?
I did not.
Small fly.
Don't need my sword.
You never do.
Alright, this guy.
This guy, I need my sword, though.
Oh my god, every time.
Every...
Fucking every time!
Compose yourself.
I'm trying!
It's the delay!
It's the delay with that attack!
It fucks with me every time!
Really?
Is that all you've got?
There we go.
Something about him.
Like, his red attack is so delayed.
I don't...
It's something...
It throws me off every time.
It's just so delayed.
I'll grab this, actually.
It's like my kryptonite.
My fucking mortal enemy.
my rival this is my rival
okay there's stuff here
they like put it up there oh what the fuck there's loot like
on the scarecrow
so much loot just lying around
it's my kryptonite it's my gary to my ash you're just fuel
for the gauntlets what oh right there i've made it easy that
is all right so much litter around me though i guess because
this is a new area
what's the point of being blue is just whoa what the fuck i
did not even see the below.
Alright.
Well, what's the point of being blue if you're still... is
there a weak as fuck?
You're still beneath me.
Triple kill, yeah.
She... gamers don't look down!
Alright, nice.
Oh my god.
I feel like every time I run around the same circle, there's
new stuff.
All right, back to the chest.
There's so much loot.
Holy fuck, it is loot for days.
I'm doing the I first.
Oh my god, spirit.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
The pillar strength is stuck at them.
Why?
I didn't even realize my heals.
I didn't even, oh my god, I didn't realize how low my HP
was!
I was just running around collecting.
Notice how it was low HP.
Please don't tell me I have to collect the loot again.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I don't even, I didn't even notice my HP.
No, no, don't tell me.
Please don't tell me I have to collect loot again.
Please tell me this is just new loot.
Okay.
He's walking over there.
No!
Okay, we won't tell you.
Oh, my god.
I didn't have to collect all the loot again.
Alright.
Round two.
Where?
Am I greedy?
I greed!
I got so greedy.
I couldn't help it.
Oh, otherwise, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't even know if I got everything.
thing.
I was going to take so much loot, too.
I have an idea.
I didn't use this.
And...
Can't be bothered.
I'm just going to use that.
Oh,
yes.
He burned the death.
Yes, I'll take those.
Piss off.
I hate that.
Nice.
Luke Goblin must loot.
I just want to loot!
Just let me loot!
Oh my god, yes?
Alright, it's fine.
That should be the last.
Alright, nice.
Okay, the chest is here.
Small friend.
Okay.
Where is it?
Oh, whoops.
I was like, where is it?
No.
Okay.
Nice moves.
And then...
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
I mean, sure, I'll take it.
Why would you set it up next to a bomb?
All right, I'm gonna, you know, I don't trust myself.
But Griffin, thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I don't trust myself anymore.
I...
Oh, there is another box there.
Oh my god, there's like loot for days.
Why do you guys...
Do they hang out in your...
You're not very smart, are they?
There's more loot.
What?
Who's laughing?
Up top?
Are they having their party without me?
Hey, hey.
Why did you invite me to party?
I thought we could.
You're a rather skillful at that.
That's on them.
See, if I was invited, they wouldn't be dead.
Okay, one of them wouldn't be dead.
Okay, maybe they'll be dead.
But it's the thought that counts.
Is there any else here?
that i missed all right let's grab the uh
i would can i would like think about not killing them you
know okay that's locked up so i can't go there yeah unless i
have to be do like this around it i wonder i wonder you know
i'll grab the dog since it's like on the way i wonder if i
can get oh you can't get that one yet okay i was gonna say
Like, can I go around it or no?
Can't tell.
Oh.
Loop.
We got the sake.
Oh.
I knew it.
I knew it was locked up.
I heard him.
They should prove no much for you.
Alright.
You know what?
Slash!
Oh, that's great.
Time to perfectly...
Oh.
Okay.
Time to almost everything perfectly.
Nice.
Where's the other guy?
Wait, when did the other guy die?
Like, did he got a heart attack?
I did not remember killing the other guy.
I hear that.
I hear the piggies.
Yeah, the guy got a fucking heart attack or something.
Disappeared.
Alright, puppy, it's time to go back to your own.
Lucky you're on my path, or you'll never return back to
there.
Or I'll never come for you.
Like, fuck it, I might as well.
Nice.
Oh, some extra chests.
Ooh, treasure.
Oh my gosh, she actually saved the dog.
I open this.
Alright, whoa!
That's a lot of missions.
We can grab that.
Wait, we can grab this, technically.
Okay.
Well, they should really stop hanging out with that guy.
There's a lot of side stuff right now.
Don't know why they keep hanging out with them.
Might be a really bad friend.
Yeah.
Pistol.
Oh yeah, now you're still...
Watch your ass!
Watch on target.
Alright.
Huh?
This way?
Oh, I have to wall ride.
You have to be like, bro, we can't hang out anymore.
Every time we hang out with you, the samurai comes over, you
fucking explode.
Like, come on, bro.
There we go.
All right, it's fine.
What?
All right, get out of here.
One strike.
Our last one.
No challenge.
All right, let's see.
Loot.
Merzaki.
Oh, and a pair?
Oh, what's my leg?
Oh my god.
Fucker.
God damn it!
It's fine, it's fine.
Got my HP back.
Yeah, you don't ambush me.
That's fucking right.
Nobody ambushes Doki Bird.
Did I miss the box?
I did.
I'll come back for it.
Actually, I don't think I will.
Oh, it's like right there.
I can get that later.
Bro, come on, guys.
Nah, cool.
Alright.
You're nothing.
Maybe they'll get scared after that.
I mean, okay.
I mean, I'll take it.
What?
Let me see.
And I did have to...
Oh, my...
Okay, it's fine.
I have the...
Alright, get over here.
I know you're scared.
Oh, you got back up.
You should have stayed scared.
Oh, that's right.
Oh, your friends are dead.
Get out of here.
Oh, you're not.
Do you think I'm done?
That's right, it's never over.
That's right, I've exes for days.
My signature move!
X, X, X!
Y!
X!
Oh, shit!
Oh my god.
Go!
It's fine.
That's fucky, right?
My signature move.
X a little bit of Y just to space things up a little bit.
Oh my god.
Bro, yeah.
Bro, are you even trying, bro?
Yeah, bro, are you even trying?
Bro, come on!
Well done.
Go back to school, bro!
Didn't even graduate in Samurai class.
You're embarrassing everyone right now.
I bet they'll never see a Porphyx.
Bro, this job's not for you, bro.
Go back to Demon's school.
Should have been a accountant, like, what mom wanted.
Alright.
And now I got my pouch material.
We have found new pouch crafting materials.
best we deliver them to a kuni yeah but the thing is I'm a
prodigy and they're not you might spend 800 hours practicing
his sword but still be ass I guess the worst part like no
matter how much you practice you can't be good at something
you like
not me though just standing there just standing there
Honestly.
All right.
Thank God for the one guy.
Nice.
Always be someone better.
Makes you want to eat a human soul after that.
All right.
Oh, there's a lot of chests here.
Don't worry, this one guy with no sword will protect the
entire village.
I believe he has what it takes he can protect the village
from Gedma
alright there you go and then there's this one you're not
bad where's my my fairy telling me to go alright Yo, he has
a stick.
Is this the same chest I was trying to go through?
Yeah, it is.
I fucking knew it.
I already forgot about the fucking forbidden chest.
All right, let's see.
We need to get...
All right, what do we want to do first?
We could get the hidden...
All right.
We'll get the...
We'll get the only portal so I can unlock more shit.
Hey, where's the shrine?
Yeah, I want to go grab the only portal for your upgrades.
Level 3 sword now.
Yeah, I just need more iron as always.
I can buy, technically, yeah, I can buy more iron now.
I have enough souls for more iron.
Oh, wait, butterfly ladies here, too.
Where is she?
Let's grab iron first before we...
God, she has so much iron.
Fuck it.
Spend it off.
Where's butterfly lady?
Oh, there she is.
Alright, what's your mission?
What is it?
Oh, it's the blind girl!
Hello again.
It's been a while.
There's something...
You're still blind, I see.
you and you alone will you listen okay another monster show
up so you're still bad yes but not here they say a faceless
has taken up residence in a house nearby a faceless a
faceless how would you know mission with no eyes well you
don't know she's just like you do you remember the older
gentleman from around here who lost his leg after what we
both went through we've been very close he treats me like a
daughter oh his son just built a house but the faceless took
residence before he could that does sound like something I
should probably look into I have heard that again we're once
posed as a god here to steal people's body parts hmm yes but
I don't recall anyone losing their entire face to him it's
like um what is that avatar uh the avatar and a demon is it
what was that guy's name again reminding me of that is it is
his name actually is his name no face a car yeah that's what
reminded me of.
Be wild if his name was No Face.
Was that a demon that steals faces but doesn't have face?
No Face?
Yeah, Coda Face Stealer.
That's what reminded me of.
A heavy restorative.
Did I see, like, the new trailer for the Avatar?
New Avatar series?
And, like, the only way to distinguish whether or not
they're, like, bender fire bender water bender air bender is
just by the color of the uniforms like i like see this
person is wearing a green uniform so he's an earth bender
just looks like yeah they're like fire rangers it reminds of
vultron
funny I can't believe Cora took away the colors too oh shit
I didn't even realize there was a person there who hey there
totally meant to save you you came in the nick of time I
hope this can go some way to repay oh yes but okay I one of
my friend sent me like a clip of one of this uh the animatic
or something uh of the new avatar girl and she like reloads
her fucking legs and I was like holy shit that's hardcore I
was like okay I was like I was like okay that's a little
stupid but like I get but it's like stupid but also like
it's stupid funny and hardcore at the same time so so she
uses her uh what's it called um what's the word call we're
like like uh when if you have like an amputee leg and you
have like those things that help you walk prosthetic yeah
yeah she uses her she so she makes her own prosthetic legs
um with earth bending oh shit i forgot my original intent
was to grab this goddamn chest so she uses her prosthetic
legs as a gun And then every time, like, like, and then she,
like, she uses as ammo.
She can rebuild her prosthetic limb with her bending.
Wait, let me see if I can find the clip.
Yeah, she reload.
She's like, reload!
Let me see if I can find the clip.
She's reloading.
There you go.
I think it's this one.
Wait.
That's crazy.
She doesn't need no weapon.
She, like, her leg's a gun.
Her leg's actually a gun.
No scope 360.
And there it is.
Nice.
More Oni stone.
My upgrades.
Which is good because we're We're gonna get there next here
soon.
Because we're gonna go to the only portal.
Yeah, rock and trick shots.
Trick shot with your prosthetic limb.
Whoops, that's not what I meant to do.
That's fine.
They're all blue now.
I can't believe it.
They took their jobs.
Dad, there's no food.
Eat all your food.
This is fun.
That's that's what you get.
That's what you get for wanting more food.
You ate all of it.
It's God It's God No No No No Food God What the fuck is
there like an archer here?
Who's shooting me Bro, I don't even see them Bro, that's
cheating Oh my god.
Okay, he's dodging.
They're both cheating.
You've never had a chance.
Use the pillar's strength.
Ready yourself.
Okay, okay, how am I supposed to use it if he's gonna dodge
it?
Alright, there we go.
Okay, how the fuck did he see me?
I didn't even see him.
All right, give me your solos now.
I need money to buy more iron.
God fucking damn it.
Where's the hair?
Where is it?
That's over here.
All right, keep crawling.
Yeah.
Here, look.
Lots of creepy crawlies out here.
This is, oh man.
Wow, what a tiny box would be a shame.
Oh, actually, nobody's here.
That's... Oh, wait, I thought enemies were gonna show up.
Oh, nobody was... Oh, there it is.
There you are.
I knew it.
I was like, there's no way there's nobody here.
That seemed easy.
It was.
Grab portal first before we grab the pouch.
Nice.
Oh, more loot.
Loot, loot, loot.
Loot, loot.
I love loot.
Loot, loot, loot.
Oh.
You're going by me.
You're on.
You're like, but how much do you love loot?
Do you love loot enough to fight him no shit okay you don't
need that head anyway he's just watching again I heard
someone love I heard somebody's birthday
oh shit
Jesus Christ Oh, it's no longer five Don't give them enough
Please What if I swear to God I never intend to give
anybody's opening
He's like She's like, come on Stop giving him I swear to God
I swear it's It's not on purpose!
He's just like, stop giving it opening!
I swear I'm not making it up!
Jesus.
Don't give them another one!
Okay, there you go.
This should be it.
That's right.
Is that all?
There you go.
That should be the last hit.
Oh my god.
It's not.
He's living with like a thread right now.
Oh, that's struggling.
Don't give him an opening, Toki.
what why are you here maybe you should help your friend
earlier oh yeah where the fuck did you two come from oh wait
what there's more all right just barster I feel like they
should have spawned earlier but I must have triggered the
boss first I accidentally trigger the boss before before I
triggered these piggies yeah I had a feeling you're supposed
to be during the fight I just let him into a different
corner oh that doesn't seem right oh mass is another boss
fight I just got a joke I heard you enjoyed your boss fight
what if we give you another boss oh that's not what I That
is fine.
Wow, Barry, thank you for that!
Super sticker, thank you!
Thank you!
Really?
Was that all you've got?
Yeah.
It's fucking red.
Let's get rid of...
Oh, he has two eyes.
Oh my god.
Wait, where's this?
Wait, oh my god, that's why he has two eyes!
Two of them!
Okay, that's it.
I'm getting a treat.
Alright, that's a little awkward.
Alright, maybe if I use fire...
Fire against water.
Surely that would work.
Here it comes.
Oh my god.
No!
Okay.
No, not again.
No, not again!
Is he cheesy after me?
Is he such cheesy after me?
No!
Oh!
In danger.
Ah!
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
Everything is fine!
I feel so... Don't give them an opening, don't you.
Everything's... I'm winning, I'm winning, I'm winning.
Everything's okay.
Not even worried.
I wasn't worried at all.
He has everything is so... We're so healthy.
We're so healthy!
And it should be...
What the fuck?
This ONI portal is like...
The fucking mixture to feed my 20 X's to access my ONI
portal.
That's how it feels right now doing this.
And to complete my escape room too.
I sense the power of the ONI.
Hidden nearby.
All right.
Masashi, what do you seek it out?
Oh no, I just realized the swords guy is blue now too.
They made him blue!
I already can't handle him when he's red!
Now he's blue!
The gauntlet is reacting to something.
Try looking around for the power of Fionni.
Inside I go.
Why is he blue?
Something must be hidden nearby.
Oh, man.
Oh, geez.
Where did they hide it this time?
Oh, it's over here.
Alright, release the only power.
Finding the dog would not change anything.
I'll just die with better drip.
Was there something I was supposed to shoot when I did that?
I wonder.
Was there another thing I can shoot here?
Oh, I knew it.
There you go.
I have a feeling.
It's always hidden somewhere.
All right, lore time, lore time.
Lore time, lore time.
Give me my lore.
We love lore.
Shizuka, my dear friend, you are the last remaining hope of
the Oni race.
Me?
I was entrusted this power by Enma, king of hell.
Shizuka in turn I entrusted to you take my place as chief
rebuild our civilization in hell
and forgive me Shizuka I was unfit she got promotion I will
not betray the trust you have placed in me you did it you
got promotion congratulations
Yay!
My wife is gonna earn more than me and I can be a house
husband.
Let's go!
I know that.
But what was that power you got?
The one from Enma?
The power that will grant me a new body in hell.
It is a gift.
Wait, I knew it!
I knew she was here!
Shizuka, chief of the Oni.
I told you, I was like, that's the worm girl.
I knew she was worm girl.
She looked like her because she had red hair.
I can't imagine anyone better for the trip.
Called it.
I was like, that girl has red hair.
Similar to the one we, the lady we saw.
Oh my god.
My wife got a promotion, guys.
I can quit my job.
What?
No, no, no food.
There's no food.
No food.
No.
You want to come inside?
Yeah, I thought so.
Stop me.
Go.
I know you come in before you leave.
Pick.
Yeah, I thought so.
Can't just look at me through the door.
You don't want to come in.
You don't.
You're gonna turn around.
Oh my god, they're all blue now.
Alright, we're this way.
He ate all the damn food.
And he's gotta live with his decisions.
He gotta live with his choices.
He's gotta realize.
Eventually the food runs out.
He has to learn that.
Oh, he got more Oni Cloud.
Should we hand the materials overtook?
Okay, now...
Alright, we gotta grab the butterfly quest here.
Okay.
Oh my god, I got lost.
Where's my Navi?
There it is.
Good night, Doki.
Hope you have fun.
Lots of fun in the tournament you're having.
Thank you for the superchat nobility.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope people have fun in the tournament.
Me too.
Me too, we'll be over.
It is stressful to organize it within a week.
Uh...
But...
He's back?
Oh my god, they...
Oh my god, they all respawned back.
Oh, that's annoying.
I mean, at least it's money, you know?
Oh my god, how am I...
Peace!
Grab him, then.
Since he's almost dead anyway.
All right.
It's fine.
These guys are nothing.
I'll just keep pressing back on.
All right, and then these guys I can one-shot easily.
Nice.
All right, we got it.
Why evade when I can slash?
Oh, wait, what?
Is there a box I missed?
Oh, it's right in front of me.
Wait, there is a box I missed.
That's not right in front of me.
It's up there.
Climb, climb, climb, climb, climb.
Nice.
Ooh, iron!
We always want iron.
I feel like iron spawns a lot, too.
Like, just spawns randomly on the map, so I don't actually
have to, like, worry, to be fair.
They should prove no much for you.
What the fuck?
I feel like I don't have to worry too much about, like,
upgrades in general.
Like, they're very generous with...
I will say, they're definitely very generous with upgrades.
Didn't even break a sweat.
Oh, yeah, tempered.
Oh, yeah, I do need temper.
Yeah, I need temper item more.
I remember that.
Alright, which is what the quests will give me.
hello ma'am what's your quest oh my are you having a worm
lead day three worms devotee oh that sounds very demon-like
oh it's a cult sounds very cult-like never heard of them oh
that's simply awful your three worms dwell within you
whether you believe it or not ma'am you're in a fucking cult
Except that is to confront your own sinful ways.
Only then can you purify yourself and avoid divine wrath.
I mean, before it was Zenpick, people injected worms in
themselves.
None of that made any sense to me.
Faith needs no understanding.
Passing one night in our place of worship without sleep is
enough.
I don't know about that.
Surely our meeting was divine providence.
Won't you want to do anything for weight loss?
You can do what you want.
It was pre-Ozempic.
Basically, you ate some...
I think it was like...
You ate some pills with worms in it.
And then you poop...
And then the worms will...
So you won't be...
So the worms will eat up all the food inside you.
And then you poop the worms out.
The good old tapeworm strat.
And with that, have a worm-ly day.
Yeah.
I think she has worms inside her.
An all-night congregation.
Doesn't that just sound intense?
Yeah, tapeworms.
Masashi, why did you say no?
I don't have time to play around with a bunch of weirdos,
Murasaki.
Well, I do, and I'm curious.
And I'll compensate you for sating my curiosity.
Well, I want to meet the worm guide.
It seems happy!
What does the worm god offer?
At least, as long as the worm's not in the brain, you know?
It was just in the gut.
Can't be as bad.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, I can enhance stuff now.
Oh!
Alright.
grade time arrows will appear the sound of period won't
refill until the arrow oh okay wait that's good murder
increase yeah as always yeah like that too is there anything
here that's good for me
large number souls are absorbed allows three charms to be
okay here's his number of souls What's this?
I don't care about that, really.
Max bow.
That's what we'd like to see.
Oh, wait.
We need that.
Wait, I need more.
Okay, that's actually really good.
I'd use that all the time.
All right, what about this?
What do I get out of these?
Reduce the time.
Reduce on charge.
Only strength slice.
For chop.
Okay.
Okay, we need to shorten the charge up time, too.
All right, we actually need more souls.
Get the iron out.
All right, yeah, we need that earth shaker upgrade.
That's a good upgrade I have.
All right, we'll go in treasure, tempered.
We'll do this one first.
We have more upgrades going in.
Because I do need...
Also need to buy the...
What was the upgrade I was looking at?
Seem really good.
I should kill him right off the bat.
Why are you running that bat?
There you go.
Oh my god, it's so strong.
What the fuck who shot me?
Oh, it's you.
I didn't even realize you saw me.
Oh, it's a deflect.
Yeah, we need a deflect upgrade.
Do I have enough now?
Wait, I have enough now.
All right, just in case there's a boss fight.
Let's grab the stamina upgrade now.
Just in case.
So at least that would help me.
Enhance.
I think it was...
No, it was...
This one.
Yeah, this is the one I always use.
So grab that for now.
Just to prepare for any boss fights we encounter.
Alright, then we go to Love Island.
Oh, I see lined up here.
There's a bunch of corpses.
So you're being festive again from the river.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
It's almost an ambush.
No, you don't.
Nope.
Get out of here.
All right.
Why I pressed V?
V for pervade!
All right.
You're nothing.
Nice.
Oh my god, they're actually They're actually learning I hate
this guy, I hate him I hate him so much
Alright, there you go He fucking, fucking ADDs trained me
Fucking freak
Actual freak
What the fuck?
Wait, he's out of the water?
What are you doing?
Oh wait, they're like toys too.
All right.
Well, that was easy.
Might have you learned the AB straight?
All right, let's see.
We got that up in the way.
And now it's the...
There's two butterflies.
But now we know they use AI for doing...
AI learning.
They have AI that's crazy.
They've new...
My entire strat!
I live this way.
Right?
Oh, I walked the wrong way.
Whoops.
Why is it over here?
Oh, it's the fucking hidden treasure.
God damn it.
Alright.
Where the fuck is this treasure?
Where is it?
It's in front of the door.
It's like right here.
Right on target.
And that's in this door?
Wait.
Maybe in front of this door?
Okay.
Huh.
Wait, what door is it?
Maybe from that door?
Maybe it's this door.
Be on your guard.
Because it's a closed door.
That's the thing.
But like, I've opened every door though.
Use the pellet's strength.
Okay, there is loot there though.
Let's get rid of these guys Get out of here One strike.
I'll take the loot though That's it.
There were no much for you at all
Trying to figure out where the fuck this painting is.
Oh, this one's a little harder because it's like
It's like Somewhere here
The wind dude?
So it's like here.
But it can't be here because...
I don't think it's here, right?
Is it in the wind temple, guys?
Oh yeah, this picture's a lot harder.
Oh, maybe here?
I think it might be here, actually.
Because it's like a locked door, but...
Oh, you guys can't see the picture.
Oh my god, I just realized I just realized I've been
blocking the picture the entire time
Okay, here it is what the picture looks like.
This is the picture It's on the other side.
Okay, so All right See we figure this out.
It's on this side Is there a door on the other side?
Nah, there's no door here.
Or do you mean on that side?
Okay, well, how do I get to that side again?
I don't remember.
Oh, wait, it's up here.
Wait, no.
Because that doesn't go take me to that side.
Or is it inside?
Is the house...
Oh, it's the house next door.
Maybe it's the house next door.
How do we get to the other side?
Where the fuck where am I anymore?
I'm actually a little lost.
Where did I walk to?
What?
Yeah, it's like...
So the beginning of the middle go right, like here?
Is there another door here?
Oh my god, there is...
There was another door.
Okay, this one was harder.
This all, that, every, the entire area around here looked
the same.
Not bad.
I will say that area was a lot harder.
Alright, let's see.
Now we gotta do the butterfly quest here.
Let's go fast travel.
Yeah, everyone, the surrounding area all looks the same for
me there.
It's definitely a lot harder compared to the other ones.
all right 10 for iron get how much souls do i have 4 000
okay we need 6 000 want to upgrade anything okay we go here
go to the butterfly and actually let's turn in this quest
first gg freaking easy so so sad that's ai makes me so upset
we've done a cover of it wasn't ai
I honestly would have loved to do a cover of that song.
It wasn't AI.
Just such a good song.
So what I saw is the work of monsters?
How terrible.
Yeah.
Yeah, I can't help but feel for the poor folks who died.
Turns out it's lucky that you're single.
It's okay to be alone, bro.
At least you're alive.
You could have been one of them.
otherwise yes uh true if i had anyone to go with i would
like been up there like a shot my thanks well think of a
trouble i suppose i better say prayer for the deceased i
thought it was gonna be our no more this generation's no
mercy you should have picked mercy you should pick any kind
of support
Yeah, but the whole, the, all the lyrics and the, um, and
the melodies and everything was AI generated, so it's not
the same.
There's no soul in it anymore.
It's not, doesn't feel the same.
There will never be another, no mercy.
I'll be Tracer.
I want to be Tracy.
Yeah, everything was AI generated.
I got the sky out of the way.
What?
Destination reached.
Hello?
I'm trying to go to this guy.
How do I have reached my destination?
What is it?
The faceless?
Bro, lead me inside.
What?
How do I get in?
I remember how to get in.
It's through this ladder?
Where the fuck is the door?
Maybe up here?
No.
I can't seem to find it.
Where the fuck?
What?
Oh, maybe up here.
Oh, there it is.
That should be the entrance, right?
Am I in?
Oh, there it is.
Hello, everyone.
I'm here to fight him.
Now I'm not too sure.
Oh, wait, now I'm sure.
Nobody would be dumb enough to make that mistake.
I know That it All right, I found it All right Yay gun With
the power of gun
Love Onimusha way of the gun way of the bow Yeah, I actually
up to here.
That's right.
Oh, shit!
That's not!
I was gonna say, are you gonna grab me now that they're all
dead?
You're nothing.
I forgot he had another move.
Wait at the bow.
Okay.
Alright, open sesame.
See him is so easy.
Oh, there's dead woman here.
Oh, she paid her in.
She wouldn't be dead.
Hello.
Oh, no.
No, not two of them.
No.
My crypt.
Now there's two.
Oh, my God.
They have no face.
Perhaps the faceless was just one of these.
I suspect it as much.
How dull.
No, now there's two.
It's just like, no.
I already have trouble with one.
Okay.
This is the only way up for me.
all right boom
wait i went down thank god i used that move i don't think i
would have won it no oh my god i took him too far i took him
too far
there you go easy okay thank god thank god i used the i
saved up my my fire flute oh my god there's a third he had a
triplet we're done all right there you go surprise they
weren't twins they were triplets the truth behind the
faceless was again with a squashed face positively tedious
why are good for maybe quadruples.
Quadruplets.
Story or not, we dealt with some monsters.
Better let the lady at Yasui Kompiraga Shrine know.
There were no faceless in there.
No, they took me back again.
I couldn't suck the souls.
There was so much money.
Oh, however can I thank you.
She took me back.
What are you doing?
from her she's blind you know if you pick on her I'll make
you regret it oh is that your boyfriend calm yourself this
gentleman just took care of the faceless in your house does
he not know me bro Google me he did my apologies how
disgraceful of me I I must repay you somehow don't worry
about it anyway I've got places to be oh i'm sorry for
yelling i hope i didn't start with you oh my bad
that's him that's the faceless the real face identity theft
is not a joke guys he just wants to retire i wonder in the
old country man until then unnoticed could he have been the
rumored faceless or perhaps it's real in any case that spine
tingling twist rather improved this story bro was just
trying to live his life so hurt the young house owner and
the lady who gave us this request are soon to be wed wow oh
it's the sun had met her after she came close with his
father and fell completely in love with her gentle soul
that's so sweet he built the house planning to invite the
lady and his father to live with him together the grandpa
like the dad match makes them surely this was the famed
fate-binding power of yasui kompiragu shrine at work
faceless or no it is a deserving it was a room rom-com all
on.
That's sweet.
Aw.
What a curious world.
Even she can find love.
Look, I'm pretty sure where we live, like, where we're
living in right now, a lot of rich people are living here.
The ones that are next to the, the ones that are next to
the, uh, the demon hunters, though.
okay we might have and do i have enough yeah we have enough
for more upgrades um which one i want to get i know it was
one of the rock ones
protection so oh this one yeah want to grab that one okay
want to grab that so you get more money too um
I don't know if it's uh might as well have so many oni
stones for it I'll just increase it just because I just have
a lot the running was pretty good to save time which one
this one oh yeah I realize I've not I'm not cared about that
one for a while all right look we'll focus the running one
again later
and we'll go up this one
no wonder I'm so got oh wow I wonder we're going towards the
ominous beam of red light hmm it looks pretty dangerous and
risks have begun to open up and close anywhere so you come
across to tame oh this is where I have to this was actually
wasn't where I have to go
Oh, my God, it's you.
God, I hate you so much.
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Don't give them an opening.
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
I got the timing.
This is in power.
Be careful.
Okay, I got the timing.
Why do you always come back?
Okay.
What?
Okay, that's a block.
That...
Oh, wait, there you go.
What do you call that?
Yes.
Oh, I got inside.
Yeah.
Unlucky for me.
Oh, my God.
It's ringing.
It's out of St. Malice.
It's fire.
I got the hit just in time.
I've got you now.
That's right.
Get out of here.
He's still alive?
All right.
God damn it.
I forgot about the other one.
Nope.
Is that all you've got?
Got the file flash.
Decree!
Finish him!
That struggling got you over.
Oh, give me that loot.
Give me those juicy upgrades.
Yum, yum, yum.
All right.
Nice.
More upgrades.
okay we gotta find the worm yeah I was gonna say I think not
even know where the worm is what do you want threatens yeah
you're so lucky let's do this you're so lucky no chance get
out of here I really need my pairs
You're so lucky there's no friendly fire, bro.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, come on.
Boom!
Bro, I'm the one doing all the work, bro.
I don't think they're leaving.
Alright.
Give me my loot.
Give me my pair.
Your dashing heroic saved the day.
Yay!
That's me!
I'll be delighted if you'd accept.
Okay, I got rice.
What?
Where is the fucking worm?
Is this way?
Is this the worm?
Worm?
I'm in the center of it.
Okay, now I'm not there.
Marked by three there.
This is where the meaning is.
All right.
Oh.
You mustn't sleep.
It won't be a very worm-ly day if your three worms tackle
you.
Don't you?
What are you doing here?
Oh, that's not good.
Oh!
It's not good.
I mean, it's just him, though.
It doesn't seem that scary.
These guys are weak.
Yeah, see?
I mean, it's just these guys.
If Doka was involved, then...
The lady earlier said they had two more.
Oh!
Okay, there's more.
We have to put a stop to the loose.
Oh, there's more worms.
I guess that's what he meant by the worms.
It's like those locust things or like those the alien face
hugger shit.
That makes a little bit more sense now.
Oh my god, not these guys.
I won't kill them.
These guys be like...
What?
Okay.
There you go.
It's fine.
Got that.
No!
Oh, wait.
There you go.
It's fine.
Okay, I definitely need a heal, though.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
That should be the last.
I hate the big guys because they can either grip me or...
getting ripped.
So I have to kill them off first.
Where is there it is.
That's another.
Oh, I can tell there's going to be a lot of guys in there.
It won't open.
Is there some other way we can enter?
I can already see it.
There's someone there!
I already feel it.
There'll be so many fucking monsters in here.
Let us continue.
Isn't it just a okay, it's just two not that bad
Yeah, how dare they how dare they not follow the Wormly
ways?
Oh wait, these guys are easy to kill this boat Wait a
minute.
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait a minute.
This is not a threat.
That don't kill creature.
She's been appropriating the three worms mythos to convert
people into Genma.
How utterly...
This might be a pyramid scheme.
They're trying to recruit more people.
And then they get, like, five more people, then they'll
become a worm.
And after they become a worm and they recruit five more
people, they become two worms.
Oh my god.
Tokyo's operating a fucking pyramid scheme.
It's not even a cook.
You gotta recruit more so they can become three worms.
Wow, I wouldn't.
I want a worm.
What?
You're not a worm yet.
Why aren't you a worm?
Oh my.
Worms, please.
Wormly day to you.
If you're here for the congregation, it's at night.
Oh.
Hi, three worms.
Then call me out.
Hey.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
I told you it's a tapeworm.
What your three worms really are?
You're wrong.
She threatened me.
She made me put those creatures in the believers.
Who threatened you?
A monstrous woman wearing a mask.
It's not my fault.
I told you.
Oh.
It's like it's the tapeworm.
It's the tapeworm shroud.
All good things come to an end, I suppose.
OK, that's it.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm not sure.
Oh my god, bro, there's a fucking guy flying towards me.
Okay, that was not fair.
I literally had a dude fucking running at me.
Like, what the fuck?
No, you don't.
I just thought I was going to hit the other guy, but I guess
he'll hit him.
I'm glad you're unharmed
All right, are you okay now?
Lady, if you want to lose weight, just walk They told me I
get my own three worms But they put monsters inside me See,
I told you she was trying to recruit me And then she got a
worm Learn from this Next time you might not be so lucky
What if the real worms were inside me all along Oh, she's
crazy Oh, she, there's no hope for it.
She'll believe what she wants to believe.
How wonderful.
What a warmly day.
Jesus.
Guys, we can't fix her.
Guys, guys, guys.
You can't fix her.
She might be freaky in bed.
Guys, not worth it.
She knows.
She doesn't.
Guys, I know the worm.
Like, guys, I know she's talking about this freaky move in
bed.
God, the worm.
But it's not worth it.
It's not.
The worm's not worth it.
I'm sorry.
Special nights.
The three worms leave their sleeping hosts' bodies and set
off to tell the gods of their hosts' sins.
Just that you'll show me the...
Guys, it's not worth it.
You do not want to be shown the worm.
The gods will then shorten the sinner's lifespans in
accordance with the weight of their trespasses.
If one could stay awake throughout that special night, their
worms would be trapped would go unheard the congregation's
purpose then was to stay up all night and ensure their worms
could not emerge most interesting of all is that young lady
what dark manner of sin is she so desperately hiding from
her god what is she i don't know she's crazy i won't i won't
be surprise was the shit she's done, bro.
Yeah, bro, bro, she believes bro believes in worms.
That's the least of our worries.
Alright.
We got the three worms done.
Alright, back to the main plot.
Alright, storyline B, done.
Yeah, enhance.
Enhance.
We still need the horn somewhere.
Is there anything I want to upgrade?
um oh the running thing i still don't have i didn't grab
power power stones
um i'll do the power of the flute just because we're there
since we're since we have a lot anyway and i do use it oh
all right i want to be sure i don't have any more side
quests here
okay all right nice all right now we can go back to main
quest line
do riffs i just need to find riffs i look in the sky and
hope a riff will show up oh yeah i don't have a third charm
unlocked now oh my god there's a lot of charms now power
easton speed i wish the stamina gauge refills reflex
increase the likelihood of get my increased regular attack
oh regular attack power okay we actually need that all right
do i have because i don't remember if i no okay i need to
upgrade that what's the upgrade for it i never got something
oh damn okay i need three power stone for that all right
i guess you'll be back here soon they told me what's going
on they said an oni is attacking villagers on mount oei and
kidnapping people
why that doesn't make sense meat to eat and blood to drink
i'd wait a no i don't want to do that how did you know while
you were all out Someone delivered us a food package and
wine barrel from Mount Oi Inside was Was what?
Stop, we can guess Oh, human parts The mafia, the only mob
Had a note Why don't have a picnic?
Do enjoy
Brady, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you
Last year I was able to be able to watch before my wedding
on Saturday Hope everyone has an amazing weekend Thank you,
Super Chat.
Thank you.
We have a great wedding, Brady.
We're going to name your first-born child after me.
It's like those kids who are like Naruto's sausage game,
Colin, or some shit.
Naruto Smith.
Brady, congrats.
I hope we have a great wedding.
I'm like Rumpus Sipskin.
Yes, name your first-born child after me.
all right let's see uh where
did i go here
oh here the new area all right i'm gonna grab more water and
pee i'll be right back guys hi baby I
am back Vince Papa Next C Mani, Zechra Ony, Stuff, Alan They
give us a super chat, they give thank you Alright, Tom Am I
half even halfway through?
I don't think I'm halfway, I think I Of all the side quests
I'm doing Quail, they give us a super chat, they give thank
you I don't know, I feel like I'm Am I halfway?
Am I more than halfway?
Oh, just have to wait and see how they spring it.
Does anyone know if I'm halfway?
Am I even close?
I'm 20% don't say that.
That castle on the mountain.
There is no doubt.
No way.
I think...
We'll suck it whether she's there.
I think maybe...
Maybe...
Part 5, I'm gonna have to do a long, only stream.
Don't say, guys, no.
I must be halfway, right?
Surely the side quest isn't pro-lying this playthrough.
But the upgrades, guys, the upgrades!
There were so many upgrades!
This is really the quickest way up.
This is more climbing than I bargained for.
A doubt this area was designed to welcome visitors.
The castle's owner must be terrible.
Oh, there's a lot of dead people here.
Oh yeah, no, I know, but I accidentally forgot about time
zones.
I got my time zones wrong.
So the Odin Musha stream will be pushed till after Dubia my
part's done.
do not worry we won't be overlapping the concert i just
forgot what time like i just forgot what time was what time
zones are so hot the stream will start after our part is
done it won't start like this moment our part is done but
you know we will be pushing back the stream i have a feeling
the story is locked watch this whoa they didn't lock this
door That's wild.
Masashi, I sense Gemma.
Me too, but I don't see him.
Oh, no.
Are they in the hay?
Find the Gemma.
Oh, oh, they're fast.
Wait, no, they're just fast.
What the fuck is that?
Oh shit!
Finally showed your face.
You're a new one.
Prepare yourself.
Oh there's two of them?
Oh no.
Are they like...
You're just fuel for the gorgons.
Oh, okay.
I can just do that, honestly.
I can't do that.
Oh my god, I can't.
Okay, I can do that, though.
Okay, yeah, get out of here.
Okay, these guys are annoying.
Oh, I can sense how annoying they are already.
Oh, these guys are annoying.
I can already feel it.
Yeah, I want to say there's loot on the other side.
They're ninjas.
I don't know.
I just find it annoying I have to, like, if they dodge
everything.
I just have to, like, counter...
I just have to, like, counter-block them.
That was low HP, but they're just...
Not very fun to fight against.
Yeah, but so I have to parry them to kill them.
Or, like, you know, the first arrow is free.
Oh, whoops.
First hero is always free.
Ah!
I hate you!
Really?
Is that all you've got?
Alright, nice.
I swore an enemy.
Okay.
all right where is the hair where the fuck is the hair all
right tell me where the hair is
this way
one of them's over here all right
One of the spotter hairs right here.
One down.
Was it just one or was there more than one?
Well, there's loot here, though.
We'll grab that first.
That was...
Oh, it is more than one.
Yeah.
Fucking knew it.
Alright, where's the last one?
Oh, come on.
I literally just...
Alright, nice.
Anything else here?
Any hidden loot?
Loot, loot.
Loot?
Huh?
I fucking...
Every time!
Why can't I quit you?
Why do you follow everywhere I go?
Ha ha ha ha!
I
hate you so much.
This guy is obsessed with me!
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
That was a fucking carry.
Come on!
Here we go.
Are you serious?
Don't give them enough.
Okay, I got this last one though.
It was worth it.
I've got you now.
You freak.
That's damn right.
I need you to know.
What are you cool about?
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
all right nice you don't need that head anyway honey make
sure not to like get greedy because i always get so greedy
all right nice just what i said that to all right
the best of me not even close not even close guys not even
worried at all was not worried oh not that scared oh nope
uh oh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you even
dokey bird suffers from an I won't leave her alone.
She really is just like me, except for her ex-murdery
axe-wielding monster.
What did you do, Duke?
What did you do to make her try to kill you?
Oh my gosh.
Not even close, guys.
Was not even sweating at all.
Good.
In fact, send me another one.
I'm not done with them yet.
Alright, into the village we go.
Just in case there's any secret treasure.
Oh, I don't like this area already.
We're in a volcano.
Hmm.
You're not a fan of this area.
Bridge is drawn.
There appears to be a lock holding it in place.
If we could destroy that...
Is there any...
And then...
I assume the boxes might have some loot?
Nope.
Oh come on!
Really?
I break those for no reason at all?
These fortifications are no joke.
Oh come on.
Get closer.
They're like something holding...
No, it's on the other side.
me?
There we go.
Yeah, maybe not, bro.
I don't think it's all end until I kill their leader.
Oh my god, I don't have the range for that.
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Grab this extra loot on the way, too.
Wait, what?
Why here?
Oh, that's why here.
I forgot about my glowing blue arm.
I forgot my arm glows blue when there's treasure.
Ah, it's just lore.
Oh, it's just lore.
All right.
We go this way.
This way we go.
I assume this is off.
No, this is actually, this is a shortcut door.
No door is ever that easy.
There's bound to be a weak spot on our way through.
To battle.
All right.
Easy.
I love it.
Oh shit!
Oh!
Easy.
There we go.
We'll get rid of this guy first actually.
Nice moves.
All right.
God, I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Oh my god, I couldn't remember if it was X or Y.
I couldn't remember if it was X or Y.
Oh my god.
He's sunlocked.
His AI glitch.
Oh, thank god.
Hit him away from me.
Praise the Lord.
The AI got confused.
Alright, this way.
Whoops.
Those explosives could be our way through that gate.
Oh, this one.
What kind of idiot leaves explosives stacked up against the
side of the gate?
As you said, game my idiocy is most reliable.
And locked this area for me.
Let him go.
Look at him dancing.
Having such a... would be ashamed of someone.
Oh, shit!
Oh, there's another one.
Okay, this one was, like, one hit.
I don't really...
There we go.
Oh, I still can't reach them.
Wait, I can.
Holy shit, wait, the head exploded.
Wait, how...
Where are they?
Oh, is they're over here?
Alright.
Are they gonna slowly run up here?
Alright, that's actually convenient for me.
What the fuck?
What do you mean you're still alive?
Oh, bitch.
Oh, my God.
Get off me!
Oh, no!
Ah!
Okay, I might have deserved that.
Maybe.
I thought she was dead!
Okay, there we go.
Alright, bro, take me out to dinner first.
Whoa!
Oh, and she went too fast.
Let's do this.
One guy that was sneaking on the job.
That seemed easy.
It was.
I'm gonna get rusty.
Alright, is there anything here?
Oh wait, okay, lowering that bridge.
But what's over there though?
Alright.
And that's just more.
Or lore, maybe.
Or maybe a treasure chest?
That's not just lore?
Nope, it's lore.
Find us keepers.
It's always lore.
No matter where I go.
It's lore.
And she was, yeah, that woman...
My game crashed.
My...
No!
My game crashed.
Oh, no, where did...
There was no save point.
Where was the...
Oh, no.
Where is it?
Where was...
Where would it take me?
The damn lord.
Oh, there was an awesome save of the Lord.
Oh, I hope to get you know, I'm gonna see I'm gonna see how
much of the game I've left honestly only Mousha way of the
sword no commentary just to see where I'm at in terms of
like How far am I oh my god no commentary got to 15 hours to
finish this game.
Oh my god.
This is not looking good for dokeyberry
15 hours for them to finish this game.
It's not looking good.
I can't.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I'm at the nine hour point.
Wait a minute.
Wait, can I technically finish this game today?
I'm at the...
Okay, no.
Maybe next playthrough.
Maybe next playthrough I can finish it.
I think, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Thank fucking.
god okay take take the lore the lore clutch yeah i think
next playthrough i'll be able to finish it all right we'll
finish this area and then we'll come out here so we have
some stuff for next playthrough for for part five
lore saved the day
oh and the save station was right here dude that's wait i
know like i had I got a new coat.
Oh, I got a new jacket.
Whoa!
Oh, my God.
I got up another tax bracket.
Guys, oh, wait, this is pretty.
I like that.
How awful.
How do I get that, though?
Open?
There's loot there.
I want that loot.
Eh.
Where do I...
Okay, I'm gonna crank it.
I don't like where this is going.
Wait, can I...
Oh, I have to crank...
Oh!
Alright.
Wait, does that make it grab this?
I'm gonna grab the loot over there.
Okay, um...
I didn't realize that that...
Wait, can I...
There we go.
That...
Okay, that was a little awkward.
I didn't think I would fucking fall all the way down.
That's all I'm gonna say.
I got a power stone woman, actually.
I hear...
Oh, they're having their party again.
They're like, none of the samurai has gone.
Resume the party.
Anything here?
That's locked.
You just fuel for the gauntlets.
Okay.
Oh my god, get out of here.
Fight me without glancing around this time.
That's a sacrifice I'm willing to take.
There we go.
Fuck that one guy in particular.
Yeah, I'm not dealing with those guys.
Yeah.
See, there's a door over there.
How are we supposed to get there?
Huh.
Ah, there's cranks for this.
Okay, we have to go back down later.
I see.
Nari Hato.
Okay, so there is a crank that I have to do later.
Oh, I can hear the monsters.
I hear the GENBA near me.
Huh?
Snowflake.
Okay.
Why don't target?
Any more?
Oh, they were trying to ambush me.
Little do they know I have gun.
Okay, so now I'm down here.
What is...
What do I get from down here?
Now I'm over here.
Oh my gosh, I'm everywhere.
I'm so lost.
And now I'm here.
Now what do I do here?
There's nothing here.
What the fuck was the point?
Oh.
Bridge.
That's the point.
Alright.
Bridge time.
And now if we go here...
Oh, and then we go back up here.
Like a goddamn man.
I hate you.
Holy shit, I hate you.
Alright, come on, come at me.
That's right.
Come on, come at me.
Fucking stupid.
I hate you.
You are so annoying.
You are actually so...
I can dodge forever.
I fucking knew it!
You can't dodge forever!
Oh my god, you can dodge forever.
Oh my god, it was a fucking crab, you fucker!
Oh my god, these guys are actually so fucking annoying.
Oh!
I hate fighting.
I think they're the worst enemies to fight so far.
Oh!
All right, where's the piggy?
Oh, hey, nice.
We actually need that for upgrades.
And we got watermelon.
Oh, I felt like I could go through that tunnel.
I guess not.
All right, now we can progress the area.
What?
That's me.
walking over.
That is?
Okay.
That was easy.
That took me right... Yeah, you saw that flick?
Whoa!
That's called being a gamer!
Do you think we can destroy this gate with explosives too?
Alright, I'll grab this first.
Alright, where are the explosives?
Okay.
What?
I don't even know where the explosives are.
I must be blind.
The game crashed again.
Oh my god.
Wait, what's wrong with this particular section?
Oh my god!
This section!
Yeah, this section for some reason.
There's too many volcanoes.
There's too many volcanoes or some shit.
There's too much lava.
Like what?
You can't sit.
You have to go to the shrine to save.
I don't even know where.
Oh no.
It's just this section.
Is it actually a really big area?
The water, the water and lava is rendered.
in 4k.
Alright, let's try again.
Guys, if we crash again, we're gonna call it here.
Alright.
It's Pragmata.
At least, like, Pragmata fucking killed my entire PC.
But this one is just specifically.
This just crashes my game.
Oh, I have to fight them again.
All right.
Wait, they're gone.
Oh, I guess not?
Oh, okay.
That's not too bad, I guess.
There's like a crank there.
How do I get there?
Oh yeah, I saw that.
I saw the fruit fly can play.
Are we actually surprised though?
Like, I don't... It's not that...
To me, it's not that surprised.
Uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, there is a...
Oh my god.
We'll do one more time.
We'll do...
We'll do one more attempt.
I'll give it a benefit of doubt.
We'll...
We'll do...
One more attempt with speedrunning.
Maybe if we get to, like, the bottom.
Alright, here we go.
It's like, I don't think it's graphics.
I don't think it's a graphics thing.
I mean, I'll try lowering it.
I don't think it's a graphics issue.
Not gonna lie.
I just think it, I...
I legitimately...
don't think it's a graphic issue but I will I will lower the
graphics just just for the sake of it new medium
yeah but my PC is cursed oh my god took me here at least see
the difference is that I'm cursed with PCs for the rest of
my life it's fine a little bit of fall damage wouldn't hurt
anybody if you move the cages again I think we may be able
to progress hey all right now I'm on medium no I I swapped
from ultra the medium there you go there we go all right I'm
not gonna try and jinx anything if it happens it happens
same kind of gates as before oh
Here we go.
I'm just cursed with it.
Every piece.
Oh, my God.
Don't give me back, Ultra.
Give me back.
Oh, my God.
It's so hot.
That's too much.
That was too much for me.
Have you come up with a way to defeat Gumbel?
My eyes.
Now we're out of the section.
We're out of the section.
think I think it's okay now surely right
wait does it okay I don't know there's motion sickness
motion blur it's motion blur motion blur is automatically
off right yeah that's the most important I would have killed
him on the way here I'm just trying to follow Takamoto's
advice for now okay we got the save now honest man Masashi I
believe that You will not be an obstacle to you for long
That makes one of us Oh, you're right, I need a save Oh,
it's too late I'm already down the elevator I can't do that
elevator again I think it auto-saved We should be fine Maybe
it auto-saved, guys We'll play with fate here Maybe it
auto-saved I like tempting fate I can't go back That
elevator ride was too slow
Alright, this way.
Oh, I can feel the Gema.
Oh, no.
It's taking me back to the lava.
Wait, no, no.
It's taking me to the castle.
Okay, it's not.
Oh, I feel the Gema, though.
It feels too calm.
It's too calm.
Where are the enemies?
Where are the Gemas?
Hey,
who's out there?
What do you want?
It's me.
I'm here to deal with your monster problem.
Shuten Doji?
You can kill Shuten Doji?
True!
Oh, he was an onyness.
This is nutting up.
Aren't we here to kill Dojo?
Perhaps.
Dojo revived Shuten Doji as with Anui.
Look, I don't care what the monsters are called.
Open up and let me kill them.
Huh?
I can't do that!
Shuten Doji is always on alert.
I'm only allowed to let his monk through here.
Who's his monk?
If I let anyone else through, I'll be eaten for sure.
He has a monk.
He roams around the mountain and brings back grub and booze
for Shuten Doji.
Grub and booze?
Of the same variety that was delivered to Rokudo Chinhoji,
I'm sure.
Oh, that's the thing that was sent.
Yeah.
That was the package.
All right.
If this Chuten Doji is another of Tokyo's experiments, is
she just using us to test its strength again?
All right.
We're okay.
This is the way.
Wait, which is the way?
Okay.
It's this other set.
I suspect that.
We'll see if there's any extra loot here.
By the way, we need that monk.
See if we can't shake some information out when we find him.
all right off we go down to kill a monk all right things
seem to be I'm the one drinks myself I shouldn't I shouldn't
say I feel like I'm just gonna make it worse I'm scared I
could happen at any moment that doesn't sound good What is
that?
Oh shit.
Oh, that's the grub!
Yummy, yummy!
Yeah, he likes to eat them while they're alive.
Alright, you think a hat's gonna save you?
Watch this.
That's like you, right?
Yeah, no hat's gonna save you!
Oh, but okay, let's actually do this now.
All right, get out of here.
It's staggered!
That's right, it's staggered!
All right, you and me now!
Oh my god, he's the eye!
Here's the eye freaking out!
That's why I like to see!
Oh, thank god!
away from me all right get out of here all right buddy give
me my pair and i guess laura too i'd get off this mountain
now now oh you have you have actual audio i'll sort
everything out you just get to safety don't get caught again
museum all right speed run this we don't know what we don't
know when i'll be alive again We don't know when I'll be
when I'll crash time is taking tick-tock.
We're rushing.
We're running against the clock
What what is the arrow oh there it is
All right Come on pick your head Come on pick your head
Oh, shit!
No!
I'm fired!
That's it.
Oh, God.
Wait, we gotta get rid of these.
I hate these guys so much.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Not the multiply.
They're multiply.
Boom.
Oh, God.
Nice.
Okay, I think I killed the other one too.
All right.
I got a little worried when I lost half of those.
Thank God.
MRSC, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Near the elder was a cave with an only weep.
It's too late, guys.
Maybe after we're out of here.
What?
How the fuck did he live?
Everybody?
Where's the other guy?
Oh, he was right behind me.
God damn it.
They're always right behind me.
Boy, I hear screaming.
Boy, we'll save them soon.
I just gotta make sure I'm not missing any items.
I'm not.
Alright, come back to help you guys.
Don't worry.
Your hero's coming.
Oh, loot.
There's so many people screaming right now.
Wait, but there's no here.
Oh, and then there's...
Wait?
My Oni glove was glowing earlier.
Wait, you guys saw that, right?
I swear to God, I had my glowing Oni glove.
Okay, maybe I gotta change my outfit.
My outfit's blue and it's fucking me up.
Shit.
Not this again.
Okay.
all right who's crying who's crying right now stay back stay
away all right these guys are like nothing these guys are
like babies you're fine get up get up give me my pair you
saved my life wait you're not from my village what's a
samurai doing here Alright, what do you mean?
I'm here to save your life.
But never mind that.
Just get out of here.
Don't ask questions, bro.
Literally, you owe me your life.
We're going to name your firstborn child after me.
Yeah, the hair's like over here.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's going to be so awkward if I didn't help her.
I mean, it'd be a just-in-time.
First time?
I'll take care of him for you.
You just focus on running away.
All right, goodbye, lady.
Goodbye.
All right, let's see.
Name your...
firstborn child after me.
Remember me.
I could have let you die.
Alright, up I go.
Oh, I have regeneration.
I don't know.
I feel like regeneration is not that good.
Alright, I have instant healings.
Holy shit!
Okay, that... There's no way I'm fucking...
Okay, come on.
Slash.
There you go.
That's right.
Too fucking slow.
You're too slow.
Alright.
This out of the way.
Yeah, get out of here.
You really think you really think you can outplay me.
Bro.
Killed your dad.
Or your dad was 20 times the fighter you were.
Alright, this has.
to be a fucking big ass fight what the fuck oh it's just oh
oh that was oil god damn it i fucking wasted it ah ah i
wasted it oh no
i think it's a very very big spotter i will not be surprised
there.
I
have a feeling.
It's a really really really big spider.
Why is there like an archer way here?
It makes sense to me.
Alright let's go.
Let's go kill the spider.
I mean sure I'll take it.
Alright let's go.
kill the other guy.
Is there more?
Don't worry, man.
I'm coming over.
Oh, okay.
Well...
I don't know.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he got me.
I got the headshot.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Oh, man.
He actually got me.
He actually got me there.
Well played, sir.
I won't be your wife.
Oh, I thought he said I won't be your wife.
I was like, damn.
Bro.
Please save me.
I was like, please.
I don't want to be your bitch, please.
Well, fault.
Alright, get up.
I owe you my life.
I would have been made into wine if not for you.
Gamma just want to find wise.
Gamma lonely.
I'm looking for a monk.
Do you know where I can find him?
Gamma's so lonely.
On the peak up ahead, there's a cottage with a water wheel.
That's where he'll be.
But I'm warning you, Samurai.
It's hell up there.
I've seen hell.
It's worse up here.
Get away what you still can.
That's true.
And hell, I don't have to do anything.
At least I don't have to save people.
And now I can open this.
Wait, there's a chest here.
I can go from outside here.
Oh, there's the spider.
That's it.
That's just one spider.
It looked like 200 million spiders.
Bodies!
Bro is compensating.
100%.
Bro is low-key compensating for something.
Aw, man.
All right.
Okay.
Right on target.
Man, I wish...
Are you serious?
I didn't even see the fucking bomb.
That's it.
I don't care.
Is that all you've got?
Oh, no.
The fucking blue.
My fucking leaves.
I'm just waiting.
No, you spit.
Get out of here.
Oh, I know there's more.
That's the worst part.
There we go.
All right, I got one of them down.
Second one down.
And then...
Goodbye.
One bomb dunk!
Shit, you fucker!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't make it.
I'm going to send a fire.
Fire.
With the power of fire.
No, you don't.
Big guy.
I'll risk it.
I'll get greedy.
I'm greedy.
Oh, now, yeah, I got the big boss.
Get out of here.
That's right.
What you're going to do now?
The big boss is dead.
Is that it?
That has to be it.
Alright.
Absorb done.
Okay, how do I get back?
Tomb is this way.
Now I have to backtrack it.
Oh, wait.
Oh, here.
There's stuff here.
And there's his.
Me likey that.
okay only power
all right shortcut get and then now i can open this door and
off we go i came into a fight not climb are we near the top
yet true where's my uber Oh no, we're back in the cave.
Are we back in the caves?
Oh no, we're back in the fucking caves.
Alright, now we got that.
Do we have Oni Stone yet?
No, we need one more.
Yeah, we need one more.
Oh, back into the caves we go.
Oh.
Aside from getting in my way, what are all these logs here
for?
No matter.
If you push them away, we can get through.
Alright, push.
There you go.
It's that easy, I guess.
Damn, I built myself a bridge.
Oh, am I dodging?
I'm dodging.
There's gonna be logs falling.
Is it?
Yeah.
Oh, so predictable.
What do I do?
What the fuck?
What do I just...
I tried!
fucking running off of this
okay they're timed alright that's good to know just parry
the logs dokey everything can be solved with parry just just
parry it they should prove no much for you I mean true she's
not wrong these guys are pretty weak
all right let's grab this is it locked oh my god did i just
fucking make up my own bridge let's go
uh oh i have to go up again all right up i go all right
let's see
it's time to time it all right okay now i got the timing now
i got the timing Oh, thank god it was...
Okay, I didn't realize that would cuck me there.
I...
Christ yourself.
For what?
What hit me?
Oh my god, that's where he is.
You fucker.
You're a rather skillful.
that all right back to the other bridge more bridges oh
these guys are easy does that make you a bead bridge or
drink thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all
right that's good that was good yeah it's all night guys
okay i need you to fly up Hey, there we go.
That's how it's done.
A masterful display.
Are you up top?
Oh yeah, there it is.
I should destroy that.
Excellent work.
That was a bit bigger than I intended.
Whoa!
And she did enjoy that.
Whoa, Musashi!
Damn.
They both had a good time.
Let's see.
All right.
It's the monk here now.
I had to do a lot to get to you, boy.
Where are you?
This stench.
Blood mixed with booze.
It reeks.
that in this cottage that him whoa oh that's a lot of dead
people in this cottage oh all right suck
floor time floor time oh that's a lot should be able to make
lots of moves
Oh shit.
It's human wine.
Oh my god, the wine are people.
The wine are people!
Never trust a free lunch.
We were just feeding our livestock.
Traitor.
dumb traitor how do you get the bones out though like how do
you get the bones out of the wine those were the people from
the village below tricked and turned into wine no one would
suspect a monk to commit such atrocious blasphemy the
perfect disguise but why would he work with the bones add
flavor he don't don't he just don't mind it yes yes say It's
like finding a fish bone, you know?
Why are you eating fish?
Would that just be inconvenient?
I guess if they're into that, it doesn't matter.
All right, up we go.
Bone broth.
Like, it's a great mix with blood.
Why does this shit and dogey bastard need such a fortified
castle anyway?
What would be rice wine, right?
It won't just be...
It won't be...
I'm thinking...
I'm sorry, I'm thinking of European wine.
I would assume it's rice wine.
So it's like That would mean Rice mixed with Mixed with lead
If Doku is unable to handle it herself This could be an
exceptionally powerful foe
Alright Let's see How much did I have any new Ones power
stone?
No God damn it, we stole my power stones Is this where A
fake monk is hiding?
Let's see real quick just in case so we're back in the caves
i don't trust the caves there's something wrong with the
caves it has like a million polygons they hit like they must
have hid like a fucking fork that has like a hundred poly
100 000 polygons or some shit mr samurai over here please
help me i'll be right there be quiet like give me i was like
don't worry i'll be right there and i was like oh
No!
I loot!
There we go.
Loot!
Yay!
Alright.
Where did that voice come from?
It's this way?
Hands off, Hellspawn.
Damn it!
Let me go!
It's not karma.
They end up getting my loot anyway, guys.
My prayer beads.
Oh.
Kind of open this up.
He seems to still be okay.
Fuck you.
You know what?
Actually...
Actually yeah.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm blowing the flute.
I'm blowing this.
Yeah, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You're not getting the best of me.
Fuck you, monsters come!
Okay, I might have fucked up.
Okay, that's on him for baiting.
That's on him.
He baited them.
I could have.
I could have fucking did it like a Okay, he fucked me over
there Bro, bro, please, please stop rage baiting him I need
you to stop rage baiting him right now I can't have him to
be more angry
Oh, you got it bro, bro, bro I'm the one trying to kill him
Get up, get up, get up I've given up hope that help would
come you saved my life.
I should I should have let him die The oh ten two later The
one's the guy that has a dead of Katie.
I was like fuck you GG and TPS diff
He's a guy that's like he's a guy that's like TPS diff Let's
do this
I did get a key.
Use the pellet's strength.
I don't think I need to because that guy was going to get
burnt up anyway.
He seems like the guy that will go GG easy.
I said GG freaking easy.
100%.
all right i got everything from here there's something else
i'm supposed to do oh it's down here right oh there's the
dungeon key gg fucking easy
just don't trust the caves bottom frag with phd and trash
talking trigger thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you true we all know a guy that's like that oh come Come on.
Dense malice is pulling the rope.
Take care.
Are you kidding me?
Oh, that's it.
I'm fucking a dope.
Nope.
We're gonna let future.
Doki handle this.
I worry.
That's future Doki's problems.
I'll always leave.
I'm leaving the poison swamp.
The future Doki.
I don't want to deal with poison swamp right now.
I just want to fight a boss.
That's future Doki's problem.
Corridokie doesn't want to walk through the boys in slump
today.
Alright.
Well, we're going to have to call it here, guys.
I think we can finish.
I honestly think, yeah, the best boss.
Don't wait.
We'll start the best boss for next playthrough.
Anyway, I think we can finish the game.
I think we can finish the game, honestly, next playthrough,
guys.
I will do a long stream anyway, because I did it as a early
stream, too.
So I'm pretty sure we can finish it.
We can finish it on what I scheduled was it on was it on
friday but yeah uh stream won't be starting at 12 30 only
because i accidentally scheduled over the concert so uh so
we're gonna i'm gonna i don't really know when exactly so
i'll push it to like maybe an hour later uh just to be safe
i'm gonna push it an hour later so to start maybe at 1 30
and then if the concert's still going on uh we'll obviously
we'll just wait until that part's over anyway guys i hope
you had fun watching i have a very busy week this today
starting today because i have to start recruiting people for
the apex tournament i hope uh i hope it'll be fun for
everybody and i'm honestly really nervous right now and
anxious and a bit stressed out uh because i guess i only
have a a little bit more than a week to plan everything um
but thank you all for watching guys i hope you guys have fun
fun watching me i'm glad i didn't crash again after that i'm
glad we we got past the cape i feel like we're going to be
back in the cave so we'll see how that goes for future
dokey.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, oh yeah, before I go,
remember to check out the merch.
Merch, merch, merch, merch, merch.
Gina Draws merch is out right now with the Sloppy Sisters,
so make sure to check it out.
A lot of hard work went into it, so I really appreciate it,
and if you guys can check out the merch.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check, get up and move around, get that blood flowing
interview.
Stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye, Tomorrow is the member stream.
We will be doing the great battle royale of your member
koon.
So look forward to the great PAL world battle royale.
Where if you die, you lose your pals and all your items that
you have on you.
So be careful, everyone.
It's the last day of the power server.
And I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye.